The names and the stories in this episode have been omitted to protect the
privacy of the individuals involved.
This is Jocko podcast number 77 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And tonight we welcome back to the show retired chief warrant officer Roger
Hayden.
And if you don't know who Roger Hayden is,
then just stop right now and go back to episode 37 of this podcast and you can
listen to Roger came on for a short period of time.
We got some time constraints on the first time that Roger came on,
but he's one of the men on which the reputation of the seal teams is built.
Started off as a frogman member of the underwater demolition teams and deployed
to Vietnam with underwater demolition team 12 and then came back and checked
into seal team one where he deployed again two times to Vietnam and then spent
30 years in the seal teams and then as a civilian has another how many years?
20 [inaudible].
So we're just looking at a solid 50 years of service to naval special warfare in
the seal teams.
So,
like I said,
Roger has been on before.
And I'm gonna tell one real quick story to kind of give a little background as
to Roger's attitude about things.
And so I was on,
and I told this part of the story last time we were on a ship,
we were,
we were having our,
our operational readiness exercise was being graded.
It's called an orb.
And the person that's grading it is Roger Hayden.
So you know,
the,
the young seal platoons were getting graded and making sure that we know what
we're doing.
And at this point,
Roger is a warrant officer,
so he's a commissioned officer and he's out on the ship with us going,
you know,
watching how we're planning and seeing how we're preparing our gear and making
sure that we're,
we know what we're doing,
like I said,
and as a commissioned officer,
you're supposed to be eating in what's called the ward room with the rest of the
officers.
So,
you know,
the military has officers and they have enlisted guys in the officer's are sort
of the managers and the enlisted guys are the workers.
Right.
And as an officer on a ship,
on a navy ship,
you have something called a war room,
which is nice.
They have,
it's just a little,
it's not even a little level of,
it's pretty darn nice in the wardrobe I've eaten in both the wardroom and on the
mess decks and the wardroom,
you know,
you have real silverware and is actually people serving you.
So the wardroom is kind of Nice.
Well Roger as a warrant officer is permitted or authorized or supposed to eat
with the rest of the officers.
You know,
he's supposed,
supposed to go get that good treatment and Roger didn't want to eat with the
officers.
He wanted to eat with the chief.
So then the middle management of the,
of the navy is the chief,
the chief petty officers,
and there's chief's senior chiefs in master chiefs.
And there are like the backbone of the navy.
They have the,
the tactical knowledge and the seal teams.
And so Roger,
instead of wanting,
instead of eating with the officer's,
he wanted to eat with the chiefs and he,
before he was a warrant officer.
What were you a senior chief before you were warrant officer and masters master
chief.
So he was a hardy,
a master chief before he became a warrant officer.
And so he started eating the chief's mess with all the chiefs.
Well,
some of the,
the,
the chiefs on the ship,
they didn't like having officer,
you know,
we don't want this officer in here.
This is our territory,
right?
This is our area again,
you know,
we can't,
why is this officer coming in here?
And so my platoon chief at the time was actually friends with,
with Roger,
but you know,
he was the guy that was getting,
had relate building relationships with the chiefs on the ship and all that
stuff.
And so they knew him and they,
and he was a senior chief and they pulled them aside and they said,
hey,
you know,
senior chief,
it's kind of,
we've got this warrant officer,
he's a CEO.
Why is he coming in?
He's not,
shouldn't be coming in here and you need to go to the,
he needs to go to the,
uh,
the,
the wardroom with the rest of the officers.
This is the chief's mess.
He doesn't belong in here.
And so my chief was like listening to them.
Oh,
okay.
Well I'm not sure why you feel that way,
but this goes on for a couple of days.
And finally my platoon chief,
and I wasn't there for this,
but I got told the story and my platoon chief was a guy from the south and he
had a great accent and talked in a very distinct manner.
And so,
so they get into lunch,
I think it was launched,
they roll into the,
the chief's mess for luncheon or an officer.
Hayden comes in and he's standing in there and he's getting a couple looks from
people.
And finally my platoon chief stands up and says,
uh,
can I ask everyone in here a question real quick?
And they go,
okay,
you know what,
what?
And he says,
well,
this here is worn off,
Sir Roger Hayden,
member of the underwater demolition teams,
member of the seal teams,
served three tours in Vietnam,
highly decorated,
including a purple heart for being wounded.
And he was a master chief before he got commissioned and he wants to eat with us
in the chief's mess.
Does anyone here have a problem with that?
And of course,
no one did nothing but crickets.
And so Roger Hayden eats where Roger Haight and wants to eat.
So Roger,
welcome to the show.
Once again.
Thanks for coming back.
I know last time we were time constraint and uh,
you said you'd come back.
So here you are.
Appreciated you coming back on.
No,
it's my pleasure.
Thank you.
And,
uh,
like I said,
anybody that wants to get the full background,
you know,
listen to that podcast number 37.
And he talks a little bit about how you grew up,
but I had a question when you join.
So you came in and your dad was Udt,
which is awesome.
And then when you joined the navy in 1965 did you know you were going to
Vietnam?
Was the war big enough yet?
Because we had this guy on last time,
Captain Charlie Plumb,
and he went to the naval academy and he,
he said he,
he graduated from the Naval Academy I think in 1965 as well.
But he said he never heard,
he never heard the word Vietnam one time while he was going to the Naval
Academy.
It wasn't until he graduated that the war escalated and all of a sudden they
realized what he was going through.
Flight Training that yeah,
you're going to Vietnam.
But when you joined in 65,
did you know,
I mean,
were you thinking,
yeah,
I'm definitely gonna go to Lauren.
Go to Vietnam?
Yeah,
pretty much because,
uh,
I'd have been drafted in the army and I knew the army was going to Vietnam,
so I figured,
I knew I wanted to go in the navy and into Udt.
My Dad never talked about it much,
but,
uh,
you know,
when I was younger I watched the movies of the Marines attack team beachheads
and getting mowed down,
you know,
rangers taken heavies and stuff.
And then I saw the bridge of the river Kwai and the guns of Navarone and I
figured,
yeah,
if you're going to fight,
that's the kind of outfit you want to find a sneak around a little bit more.
So yeah,
I did.
In fact,
it was soon as I got in to the navy,
I,
uh,
I took the screening test and all that stuff.
And you know,
before I even went to,
no,
right after,
when I was at radio one school,
I was a radio one,
so do it.
There was a 22 week long school and that's what I did is I worked and did all
that stuff and did the screening tests and the,
you know,
and uh,
they wanted me to go to Rhoda or some other navy insulation because they didn't
do too bad and radio one score.
It wasn't the number one guy,
but,
and I went,
no,
I'm going to go to Udt and so,
and then you went to what?
The u
they we,
our class,
our class wasn't starting up for about six months,
so they stuck me on the USS Paul Revere 32nd street waiting for a Udt training
and I was a designated semen back in the day.
A designated semen was pretty good,
wasn't like it is now.
And I figured I'd work in the radio shack or something like that.
We'll soon as they checked the board,
they put me mass cook and I was down in the scullery loan.
We went down there,
there were two other guys that were waiting for a 22 that were in the scullery.
So we sat there and did that for six months and got off the ship and went next
door across the bay there to training.
Yeah.
That's something that the navy,
it's,
if you're a new guy,
everyone talks about how new guys get treated wherever you are in the military.
But in the navy,
when you,
when you show up to a ship,
you doesn't matter,
you have to work in the,
uh,
in the scullery which is washing dishes.
What is it,
a 90 day stint you got to do in that?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Pretty much 90 days are,
and you only don't do that if you're an e four and above.
Right.
And we did,
I did a deployment where we had a guy that was in ESL but he was an e three and
you know,
he was saying,
Hey,
oh wait,
how am I going to get out of this,
you know,
doing the scullery duty.
And we're like,
you're not,
that's the rules.
You know,
you're going to go do it,
do it.
And I was a senior Keith,
two of us,
a guy named real good friend of mine,
we couldn't get her flight back.
So they put us on an Arg,
the float back here to San Diego and we kept Paul over,
guys from the next cook and that were seamen.
That's,
we just went,
we got stuff to do or doing training and they haven't got time to do that.
So we kept him out of,
of course I was a senior chief then and so it was,
so we had little pole plus the Kava,
the boat.
He really liked us a lot.
And uh,
you know,
the,
the CMC and he was a PBR Vietnam guy.
So we get along really well.
Yeah.
Well,
and actually this kid that ended up making me four luckily before we went on
deployment,
so he's scared out of it.
But,
uh,
I would still do it
bringing in the supplies and stuff like that,
you know,
cause it was a good workout.
Yeah.
I forget what they call that and Reps.
We did that too.
Yeah.
I actually,
when I was on my first deployment,
I deployed to Guam and you know,
we just did whatever you wanted.
I was 21 years old.
It was completely insane.
You got all this per diem money.
You felt like the richest.
You will never mind fell like you were the one just guy you ever met.
I mean you,
you never made any money when you're 1617 years old.
Do you get in the seal teams,
you're getting all this money and then they go overseas and they're giving you
per diem.
And so you're the richest dude in the world.
You have very limited responsibilities cause you're a new guy in a seal platoon.
So what do you do?
Just get crazy and get after it and you know,
you're doing whatever you want.
And then my next deployment was on a ship and we pull into the first port and
they say,
uh,
you know,
e four and below liberty expires at 10 o'clock and I was like,
Oh yeah,
whatever.
You know,
I'm a seal.
And they were like,
no,
actually you'll be back on the ship at 10 o'clock and there was no way around
it.
And where there was ways around it,
we found ways,
right.
You know what the way around it was,
I'd put my PT gear in a backpack and then go off the ship to go out,
whatever,
and then hang out all night until five o'clock in the morning and I put my PT
gear back on.
I'd run,
get a sweat going to walk up the brow and whatever.
I was coming back and say,
yeah,
I was just out for a run,
got my rock on.
So there was ways,
there's ways to make it happen.
So speaking to guys from,
from when you were going through training,
was there guys,
when you're going through buds training,
was there Korean,
Korean vet,
Udt guys in there wasn't a World War II or was it just Vietnam guys have early
Vietnam guards?
Yeah,
World War II guys.
There was one guy named um,
um,
Goddamn and Tom,
great big tall guy,
crew cut
and,
and he was a World War II.
Udt Guys,
let me tell you this story on that guy.
So we're out of,
we just get the same committee,
the last part of the training,
you know,
third phase,
so we're all lined up there.
We just got off.
We went out there,
I'm an Lcu,
you know,
with all of our demo and ammo and all that other crap.
We just mustered out there in this guy comes walking up,
great big tall guy,
real old,
what was I,
1918.
You know what I mean?
He looked probably like,
uh,
you do or I do.
And we thought it was an old guy,
but he looks at us and he starts talking,
you know,
and he goes,
goddammit,
uh,
I'm the,
I'm your demo instructor.
And uh,
keeps talking to me.
He says,
I don't Brooke,
no bullshit on the ranges,
you know,
and we're kind of just looking at him like,
what the hell?
And he gets himself,
worked up a little bit and he goes,
um,
matter of fact,
uh,
anybody that screws up,
we'd just go out behind the shitter and get it squared away,
you know,
and work still looking at him.
He talks a little bit more and get some self all excited and shit.
And he goes,
matter of fact,
anybody wants to guy behind the shitter right now?
We'll go,
you know,
we're just looking at,
well come to find out later on,
it was in the 82nd airborne and jumped into Normandy,
got captured,
escaped on and on.
And then he was in the Korean War too.
That was one of our instructors.
Almost all of them there were in the Korean War,
you know,
pretty much.
But,
uh,
then we had another guy
and um,
on his jacket he wore,
he had a Udt instructor and the other side was God,
you know,
he was,
he was a hook nose Indian Apache and he was a bad ass dude.
And then they had some great guys.
And now most of the instructors,
yeah,
we're a,
and some were Vietnam guys,
you know,
like,
um,
had this one blue eyed guy,
he was,
oh,
I can't think of his name right now either,
but he was,
I'm
on vacation,
was paddling up north in
the Columbia River,
so,
no,
not that north,
the east coast side.
And uh,
his,
he was a on a excursion with some other people in his canoed tipped over.
And,
uh,
he was real cold and shit and he was trying to swim a couple of them to shore
and Shit and just uh,
just one out.
But this guy would run behind you and you of course we didn't have a lot of hair
but what we had stood up,
you know and you turn and look and there he was just staring at,
she had these blue eyes,
you know,
I'll think of his name in a minute.
And real good guy though.
And there,
there must've been a cause is pretty regimented now but they must have had,
no it was,
it was definitely less regimented when I went through for sure.
It must have been completely just like no rules when you went through
now wait,
this guy,
during hell week he had what they called the swimmer line and like I say,
we're on the bay side mind you were in training in January,
started three January seven colder and God,
you know what he would do as a,
we had all,
he have us hook into what we call the Florida board line.
You know,
like you,
when you do recon is a guys hold on the line,
you move down the line and stuff.
And uh,
he had sent us all out and hell there is about,
okay
fuck you about 60 of us,
excuse me,
good.
Send us out.
And we had to be in a straight line if we weren't bringing us all back and line
us all up again and we weren't straight.
So he sent us out again,
brought us all back in and we're freezing.
The guys are almost getting hypothermia cause we're not,
we're just in a k pocket,
not your regular utilities that you wear for training.
Yeah.
So he sent us out again the third time and like if you're on the bitter end
line,
you're,
you're screwed.
You know?
Then he brought us back in.
He goes,
well God damn,
I guess it still wasn't very,
uh,
you guys still weren't in a straight line and we may,
we're going to have to send you out again all the way down the line.
All you heard was click,
click,
click.
We just looked at him.
Wow.
All right.
We got other things to do,
but it was it.
We're done man.
Every day he had a loss of yeah.
Class
that was so cold.
Yeah.
People always,
uh,
if,
if you don't know California and you think California is like Baywatch,
the old TV show,
do you think the water's all warm?
It's not warm.
Especially in January.
Yeah.
January 3rd it's not going to be warm.
And,
and you were saying you guys were swimming like crazy going through that because
you knew that you're going to Udt
that's it.
So you're a frog.
Frogman that's what you're being trained for,
not seals.
So we did a lot more water work.
And you guys did going through buds because we didn't have the seal portion of
it.
We got that after we made our deployment,
came back,
went and seal team.
Then you went to a cadre.
Yup.
Did you get any land warfare at all?
Oh yeah.
A little bit more like basic stuff and a little immediate IUD has been immediate
action drills,
but not much.
It was a,
like our last stop that we had,
I think I told you this and uh,
on thank you.
Many was a,
we did swim or scouts in on the other side of,
uh,
a rock formation.
We called bird shit rock and got to the island.
They gave us all a 40 pound hammer sacks and we went from there all the way 23
miles to the end of the island.
We blew up walking.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you Hump 23 miles after you swam over the
yeah.
And then came back and attack the camp.
That was our last top.
Hm.
That's a,
that's a crappy patrol two does cactus,
I know
I was smart.
I was thought I was pretty smart city,
so I wore a,
um,
kind of a,
what sue,
what do you call that?
The small one,
you know?
Oh,
like a wetsuit.
And because I,
you know,
so I wouldn't freeze to death coming in.
And actually this was April,
almost the end of April and it was still cold out of San Clemente,
you know,
so we swam in and I hummed to that thing on all the way up there and it got
sunny and warm,
almost frigging died back.
You can peel it off me like this.
There's no good,
there's no good way to do it.
There's like no good way to handle coming over the beach is not going to be
convenient.
You're not going to be comfortable.
That's one of the things that makes,
in my opinion,
the one of the things that makes the seal team,
the guys in the seal teams are really good,
is that we just have to deal with the water and as soon as you're dealing with
water,
like you just said,
there's no easy way to do that.
Like you're going to either be freezing in the water or you can be sweating on
land or you're going to be too hot.
Oh No,
actually you're not.
You're going to,
you're going to be okay in the on the,
on the land.
It's,
you're just screwed is what I'm saying.
And not to mention your weapons,
your weapons all get your radios all get jacked up,
your weapons all get jacked up,
your gear gets all jacked up.
You got sand in your boots,
there's no good way to deal with it.
No,
there's no,
and on top of that,
the communications,
like you're in the water,
you can't talk to people,
you can't,
there's no radios aren't working.
It's just everything sucks.
And so when we were do ops dry,
it just seems like it's so easy to do.
And I think that's the one big thing that separates,
it doesn't separate us,
but it's one of the things that makes us good is that we have to deal with the
water and we deal with in our whole career.
Bottom line is you should never bring a boat to shore.
You always swimming.
Yup.
That's what we do.
Just like swimmers,
scouts,
the whole nine yards.
That's the bottom line was a chief.
I was pretty hard on that stuff.
We never brought the boats to shore.
Yeah.
You know,
we,
we did the same thing when we were in the art platoon.
We never brought the boats in because there's a,
there's that 10,
15,
maybe 20% chance that you're going to flip a boat,
you're going to lose a boat,
something's going to happen to a boat,
and then you're screwed.
Now you got to bolt washing up against the shore and you got to deal with it.
And it's a big no,
we always swam in it.
It's a big,
it's a big target.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
In Desert Storm,
you know,
and we inserted those coin.
He's the,
uh,
officer,
I won't mention any names,
but wanting to bring both the boats in,
you know,
and into Kuwait and let the Kuwaiti guys off and I went,
no,
he keep at least if you're going to do that,
keep one bolt back.
Even if he keep another bowling shirt because they can give cover he fire,
you know what I'm saying?
And then if they have to,
and he,
and you know,
you can be seen,
you know what I mean?
It's,
that's a big target,
you know what I mean?
You just don't do that,
you know?
No,
that's,
there's so many things.
You've got to figure out what the water and when you,
when you guilt.
That's why when we were in Iraq and we rarely did boat ops,
we did some in,
in,
in the river.
But you're just telling all either on foot,
it just,
everything is so much easier.
It's crazy.
Uh,
that you get,
so you get done with training Cinco de Mayo,
1967 you get done with training and you check into Udt 12 and you didn't really
know too much about the seal teams,
I guess.
No one at that time knew much about the symptoms.
And you were saying on that first podcast that we did that the platoons weren't
really formed up yet.
You kind of showed up at Udt and you're,
it's,
it's kind of a loose situation,
but do you do,
do a workup call?
Once we started
working up then it was regimented,
you know,
you knew what cad to do,
but we had a while they had just come back and relieved a UDT 11 had just
deployed and then 12 came back and you have a kind of a stand down for about a
month or two showed up for them.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cause it's a nine month deployment for UDTs.
So you have about a six months workup and then you have three months where the
guys go on leave schools and stuff like that.
And we came,
I came in just at that time,
so it was really kind of like,
uh,
we'd go up and do what they call silver slippers up at a Pendleton when the
marines are doing fibia slide needs and we'd be the lifeguards and stuff like
that.
And you know what I mean?
Until we start forming up and start working,
then it got,
it got pretty good.
What did you guys do?
Was that where they hardcore about PT back then?
Oh yeah.
What'd you guys do?
Team pts,
platoons or team?
Team.
The whole team?
Yep.
And was it every every day?
Was it the same?
Was it flutter,
kicks,
pushups,
pull ups,
basic PT.
In fact,
I did and start lifting weights until I was in about
15 years,
maybe 16,
17 years because a,
you do old corners swimming.
All the PT we did and everything.
We were in really good shape.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
And you didn't see a lot of the guys in the gym lifting heavy and stuff that
came on later on.
Then also,
which I changed when I was later on when I was a chief and a senior chief and
stuff.
And uh,
even,
uh,
no,
not as an LPO.
We still did platoon PT every morning.
But uh,
we'd do it every other day then let the guys go off and do their running,
do there Pete weightlifting and stuff like that and they'll work out well,
you know,
you can change.
Even though I thought PT in the morning,
first thing it was the best to do,
especially when we were in Subic and
half the guys would be thrown up and stuff.
We were doing PT.
Yeah.
I always like we used to at team one when I got t one there was that,
that team PT we did everyday and team two is the same thing,
but you know,
I'll tell you once the war started,
there's a lot less focused on PT n it just was and she wore a yard to Jocko.
You can't really go for long runs and shit where you're in a rock and
we'd run around bases.
Did you guys have,
uh,
my,
my question is,
uh,
did you take weights with you?
Did you have a workout place and stuff?
Yeah,
that we deployed and actually once one team shows up somewhere on deployment,
they all bring a bunch of gear and then there's enough to do it to get it done.
And then other teams,
they don't have to bring everything,
but they'll bring more stuff and eventually,
you know,
whatever compound here in is pretty nice.
If you go to the bag saved,
calm down.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I was bribed,
brought maths for,
for Jujitsu.
I'd make a little Jujitsu area so I could still course
so I could still train and get the boys trading.
And um,
do you know what's funny too is like you were talking about it,
it's weird how some of this stuff stays cause you were talking about walking
around in Udt shorts and,
and choral boots and,
and unfortunately UDT shorts.
I don't think guys wearing them,
I don't think they even get issued him anymore.
But when I got the team one,
we absolutely got issued UDT shorts and that's what work.
That was our uniform.
And we got issued coral booties,
those old gray coral booties.
And I didn't realize,
you know,
that's what you guys wore and that's,
that's something that they've probably been issued for.
I Dunno.
He went out in town,
you'd see guys with the core Blue Levi's and there were all actual auction
stuff.
You know what I mean?
You can pick out a team guy in a heartbeat.
Yeah.
I,
I was,
uh,
I looked,
I looked up coral booties and I was just seeing if anybody makes them anymore.
They're hard to get there on Ebay.
You got to buy a pair on Ebay,
you gotta be lucky if they have your size.
I got to go through my gear and see if I still have my choral booties.
Um,
but,
and then you did do a legit work up though,
where you did all your hydro recon.
Yeah.
Only last hour.
We cons,
uh,
like a up the coast by Penelton.
Uh,
we'd drug this one rocket looked in thing in up over these fucking mountains and
put it in the lake and stuff like that.
And then we swam across the,
uh,
well did we swim?
No,
we didn't right there at the channel and it goes out and you have those old gun
emplacements and shit,
but it will attack those.
And they had them set up of booby traps and stuff,
so we'd go across and work her way up and shit like that.
Always stuff.
Yeah.
And Udt it was,
it wasn't bad.
It was good training.
I mean,
but it wasn't,
you know,
like a story I told you it was,
um,
during the 67 68 tet,
we're in Dong Tam on the ass.
Scary.
And that's when we were who I was with Udt and there were about 17 of us on
there.
We're doing that dark thing later on,
getting that a little bit more.
But uh,
that's when we worked with the ninth infantry and stuff.
And uh,
anyway,
uh,
they had a seal platoon in Mito,
which wasn't too too far away,
but it was right in the town.
Why these coasts would have a,
would have a place in,
in a town.
I'd never know because anytime you left her when any work,
you know what I'm saying?
You can be picked out.
But anyway,
so they were almost getting overran,
but they were on the tallest building.
They had a 57 recoilless rifle and stuff.
Anyway,
they send a call out,
hey,
we need help.
And there were 17 of us,
you know,
on the ass.
Scary Udt guys.
We wanted to go in and rescue them and save them.
And our officer,
just a great guy,
lieutenant said,
now he ain't going anywhere.
We're so proud.
You got an in their helicopter.
We don't know.
Don't even know.
We just wanted to go and help him pay card ready to go.
Yeah.
You know there are seals but the t guys do.
So anyway.
So,
um,
we didn't do that.
And then I got back from deployment when the seal team went to the cadre and
then those guys,
by the way,
they didn't get overrun.
No,
they,
they've them on.
They were coming up,
the stairways never thrown grenade down at him and stuff like that.
And then finally the Arvin and the u s came in and took me to go back over.
It was during the 67 68,
10 you go bad.
But anyway,
so when I got back and I went through cadre Sefa found out,
you know,
all day we weren't ready for this.
We didn't know any immediate action drills.
Well not a lot.
Not,
not,
you know,
pounded of newer head roll.
We'd automatically think about them,
any urban environment whatsoever.
Say Plus we were in urban and that was urban would add our asses handed to us
cause we didn't know we were fighters would have fought.
But,
you know,
figured those guys in me told the VC and stuff there,
they had their shit together.
That was their town and stuff.
You know what I mean?
We'd,
uh,
you know more about the urban stuff than I do,
cause they never fought urban,
you know,
we'd hit who chews and stuff like that,
but we never swept through.
Uh,
we did one village one time,
but it was,
you know,
it was good.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And so when you deployed to with Udt,
did you guys write a ship over there?
Do you fly over there?
How'd you get to Vietnam?
We flew over to Subic Bay and I'm like,
I said,
uh,
that's where we were at.
That's like,
you went to Guam.
We'll sue because our place who be pay and then,
uh,
they would,
would fly over to,
uh,
we had different debts that we hadn't Vietnam,
like in Denang,
they had camped in Cha and from the Nang you'd workup and around food.
Why Way?
Quine three Dung Hall,
the northern part of the area and stuff,
you know,
and then we got on the Diatchenko and I'm don't know if we picked the Dutch,
she incorporate Subic or not.
We might have.
And then when,
when we did all them Beecher's guns and then the next debt I went to was down in
Dong Tam on the [inaudible] back to Subic inbetween at all.
Oh yeah.
Oh really?
And we'd be there for about a month or three weeks.
And
so we had to basically deploy from Subic out to Vietnam,
do operations for a month,
then go back three months,
over three months in three months at a time.
Yeah.
Well,
but it's a nine month deployment.
Yeah.
So yeah,
we,
my three deaths were Denang then under Diatchenko and then down in Dong Tam when
I,
as in Udt.
And that was three months at each place.
Yeah.
And first of all,
on the last one you talked,
talked about doing 130 miles worth of beach week.
It was about 120 I think.
Yeah,
it was three months.
I mean,
you know,
but you know,
you were kind of talking about it like,
oh you know,
we were doing this weekend,
but that was,
you were,
you were recounting beaches in north Vietnam.
No,
south South Vietnam.
And was there any resistance?
Were you guys in jeopardy of getting rolled up or was it more of like almost an
admin thing or was it somewhere in between?
Okay.
We,
we always had to either marines or the arb,
which was the south Vietnamese army.
They would screen put screens out when we'd do the beaches to cover us in case
we got hit with anything.
Right.
Cause they were,
nobody knew what was really on the beaches and stuff.
But if the marines were in the area,
they'd had sent a patrol and they had worked the back back chores and stuff as
we're doing our recon and stuff.
And the one that I've told you I,
we got hit was we didn't have any army,
army or marine.
So we sent two of our guys in the back to kind of check things out as we're
doing a recon.
And that's when we got cotton.
At almost cotton that a l shaped ambush.
And uh,
what happened was as we were coming down the beach and we had the guys out and I
was a good talker first saw,
I was out front with another guy and I had a pair of bathing suit,
a UDTs on coral booties and my super sweet and I was writing in the back shore
information
so everyone knows what we're talking about.
When you're going to land people on beaches or if you're potentially going to
land people on beaches,
you have to do a reconnaissance of the beach,
but not just of the beach itself,
but of the water and how deep the water is and make sure there's no obstacles in
there.
And so the people that did this since World War II was the underwater demolition
teams.
So that's what we're talking about.
The way you do it is you,
you have a,
literally,
you have a line,
a big rope.
It's small,
it's more like a line than it is real.
But that stretches from the beach,
from a couple guys on the beach called the beach party all the way out to a
boat.
A small little rubber boat.
Yeah.
And that was an IBS.
We hooked it tune,
it's about 30 feet as knots where you know each pair is going to be holding onto
and you mark take the sounding than you as you went to the next sounding,
which was 25 yards down the beach.
And on the beats it'd be holding up these,
uh,
markers so that you could get yourself on them.
You'd be dippy doing down until you got to that point again.
Then you'd take your sounding mix and then he'd come back and make a
hydrographic charts.
So there's guys on the beach that are holding what we call range markers and
they're set,
what did they sound like?
10 yards apart,
looking at one guy in the front,
one guy in the back,
and they're looking at a compass so that they're making sure that they're lined
up.
So that lines up this whole line.
So it's this,
it's this kind of complicated in,
it seems like an administrative thing,
but you got to do it.
Otherwise,
you know,
you get a situation where the marines come into land and they hit a,
like they did.
Yeah,
they did an entire war and they handle no big data,
a reef and then they dropped the ramps,
the guys get out and they didn't know that that reef was only 10 feet long.
It's two feet deep.
But now on the other side of the reef there guys are going into 10 1215 feet of
water and drown.
So that's why you have to actually be fairly precise or as least as precise as
you can be when you're taking these,
when you're doing this hydrographic reconnaissance.
So
yeah,
have the back shore party,
you know the two guys there and they have the officer and a couple of other guys
picking up the stakes,
the stakes out and that's usually cartographers job.
You were way out ahead of everybody else taking the back shore information so
that when you come back and do your I do graphic chart,
you know,
you,
you can lay it out.
Exactly.
Then you have to do Leroy
and I was a cartographer.
I know all the ships.
So which I hated the man.
Make your hand draw the maps,
your hand drawn that and those,
those,
those charts that you draw that you're going to present,
those are going to get presented to,
you know,
the,
the navy and they're gonna use those charts to conduct is landing.
So like I said,
they gotta be good.
You gotta be good quality.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so,
uh,
there are two guys are walking along and we were doing or beach reconnaissance
and everything.
Well,
they,
uh,
had an l shaped ambush on us and they had a spider hole back here with a cup of
guys that once we got hit and if anybody ran back,
these guys in holds him down or two guys hit those two guys and the spider hole
and opened up on them,
which made them open up on the sooner.
So we all leapfrog back down the beach.
Really great guy.
Mean he took charge,
everything was perfect.
We grabbed onto the line to bolt the IBS took off and you know,
nine and a whore,
nine and a half horsepower range and didn't go real fast,
you know.
And then we had a coast guard cutter out there.
They started lobbing in a Willy Peter on them,
but we didn't know it was them and some of it landed pretty close to us.
So we thought there was them doing,
trying to hit us and we,
we got out far enough and our pl that we finally got to and got on appeals.
Uh,
you know,
the both that the,
uh,
that we inserted it off of and stuff.
And,
uh,
they picked us up and the guy who was shooting is 50 and stuff.
But what was really neat was income.
These two jets.
Oh.
And they napalm the whole beach.
That was,
that was kind of cool.
And that's when I told you when I got back to the boat,
I said,
screw this naked warrior shift.
I can't hear you.
So you're in a pair of UDTs call booties with walkers.
They're like,
they're like chuck converse.
Chuck Taylor's a little bit leaner.
The split for the,
no,
it was just like Congress.
So you could walk on coral,
get cut,
hold you down.
They're not big.
They weren't,
they were like,
they were canvas and they had a kind of a rural,
thick rubberized bottom on it day.
Yeah,
they were good.
And then,
uh,
I had an m 79,
so I'm shooting that thing as I'm running back and stuff.
Then that's the only weapon you have,
is it?
That's all I had that in your slate to draw on.
Yeah,
collect back shorter for me.
I see.
That was kind of exciting.
And was that before you,
was that,
was that recon before you work with the ninth infantry?
Yeah.
Okay.
I went from there,
from the Diatchenko down to Dong Tam and work with the ninth infantry and the,
uh,
the ninth infantry man.
So this stuff I was looking about,
you know,
about the ninth infantry and what they did and just first of all,
the ninth infantry is the,
is the unit that the fictional character Forrest Gump was supposed to be
attached to,
which is why in the movies working by the water and all that stuff,
I imagine that's what they,
that's why they picked it.
Uh,
the ninth infantry in Vietnam had 10 medal of honors awarded to soldiers and
three sailors.
So they were working in conjunction very closely with the Brown water navy,
which again,
to pull a quote from the last time you,
you were on Roger,
you're like saying that job as being brown water navy was just vicious.
John Vicious job and general Westmoreland said that the Ninth Infantry Division
and the mobile riverine forces saved the Delta region from falling to the north
Vietnamese during,
during tet.
That could have been,
I mean,
I didn't,
I wasn't on land with them.
Don't know where we're thinking.
We did remember I was a second class then and we got,
we were on the,
uh,
the um,
ask Gary in Benawashi as a reconnaissance guys.
We ask Gary and better water once they were apds.
What's that?
Um,
uh,
and Tibias some,
some kind of an amphibious ship.
Yeah.
Both of them were big ones and croup chips coop.
I think the ask Gary was a troop ship.
I'm not sure.
It could have been the Benwalk too,
but they were pretty good size ships and they were right at,
uh,
on the,
right at dawn cam,
which was the Dong Tam when it had a big army base and a navy base.
And late my third trip to Vietnam,
I went back to her as a seal and it was a same,
same place,
same area.
So when you,
how did you guys get linked up with the ninth infantry?
Well,
we,
uh,
that's who we're doing the reconnaissance 40 to thank you.
Go up the canals and up the rivers,
you know,
see what the depth was so they could bring the uh,
the Brown water navy up there that the troop carriers and stuff like that for
the ninth symmetry and they didn't know what the depth of the,
some of the places they were going to go in.
So they dropped us off on these,
uh,
we called them the dark,
they were like a jet ski except you didn't sit up on him.
He laid down on them,
use your feet to guide them and they had a 355 degree camera and a feather
kilometer and they would dig to have a sub drop us off and we'd come down and do
the reconnaissance.
I mean take soundings and take pictures of Nolan's point,
like a pagoda,
more another canal coming in or something.
You know,
we'd come back and we'd do a chart and we'd give it to him and that's what they
used those charts to go up and do their a amphibious landings.
But you can only go up those down,
those things maybe once or twice.
And then you didn't do it again because it'd be waiting for you.
So when we weren't doing that,
which you can only do so many of them,
then we started writing with the ninth infantry as their demo guys
and,
and so you would,
would you have already seen it because you do the dark mission and then you'd
come back and then they'd come up with their plan and then they'd say,
okay,
we're going to go up that river that you just came down.
So you'd be from we,
would you be familiar with it now?
No.
If they took us,
we went up to four corners and the places that we had never been,
that was deep enough for him to go up and stuff.
But uh,
they might might've,
I don't know.
You know,
that would have been John Odish.
My Ot would have probably been in on the planning when they were going to go in
something and talk about our charts and stuff,
you know,
memorize just a booger reader,
one of the guys in the dark,
you know.
And uh,
but then they said,
okay,
we're going to need you.
What were the lock,
I know you were saying on the last podcast that they had these log dams at the,
Oh yeah,
they'd put dams across logs and stop the boats up and just different obstacles
and shit or bunkers long.
And uh,
we'd go in and blow up the bunkers or blow up the log dams,
you know,
if they had them.
And that's what I said.
They first put us on what they called an Alpha boat,
which was the lead boat and they had one in the rear and one of the front.
And,
um,
what would they look like?
Um,
God,
I don't have a picture of where I can show you.
I actually asked anybody looks,
looks up on the ninth infantry.
There'll be able to see them.
But anyway,
the Alpha boat,
we were on one of those.
And that's the one I told you we got sunk on cause it'd be 40 rock and hit us
right in the exhaust and things started going down and we rented to shore.
If it had been a little bit higher to hit all those stacks of a c four,
we had so but and then they started putting us in about the third or fourth bolt
back.
They didn't want the big demo load in the front alpha boat.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Pretty much figured that one out.
So your boat gets hit with a rocket and it starts sinking.
And in the the,
was it like a chief front of the boat?
No,
I was,
could have been,
I just know her first class or something and they ran us up and then it starts
sinking down and we got off,
did a little perimeter and then the um,
as IPL bolt came up and just holds everything down and we swam over to the Zippo
boat and got off the Zippo boat.
So named because after the Zippo lighter because as a flame thrower,
yes.
Right,
exactly.
I know I popped this stuff off like people know what it is.
You'd hadn't been there to see it,
but I mean it came zipping up and then we swam over to it and we got on it and
got out of there and you got everyone out of there or nobody got hurt or killed
on that just that'd be 40 rocket.
And they started opening up at are the boats opened up to,
and they had fifties you know,
Jesus Christ,
20 minutes.
Did you try and salvage any of the demo and leave it?
Well I actually blow it and we were going to come back and do that,
but they decided to have VOD do it.
So EOD went back and blew the bolt up and all that crap.
So yeah,
cause it was just partly out of the water and stuff,
but they pissed us off.
We're underwater.
Demolition was like,
you know,
WTF,
you know that,
you know,
that's what we do.
Well the EOD guys,
I guess they didn't have a lot to do,
so they sent him down there.
I don't know if it was army or navy EOD,
but who knows.
It's always good to blow things up.
That's one of my first deployment I returned rack.
We didn't blow very much up.
And when I went to my second deployment to Iraq,
I kind of had the attitude is if we had the opportunity to blow something up,
we were going to blow it up.
It seems like the smart thing to do,
being able to take it apart,
polling place you load in place and uh,
that one,
you know on the,
on the last podcast you were talking about that one operation that you went on
and you,
it was basically a giant ambush against the whatever,
seven or eight boats that you guys had that the ninth infantry had and they must
have been prepared waiting for you got for this group to show up.
I mean,
what do they,
what was the enemy that well organized at that point?
Stay warm and Nice,
but when you got psyops guys dropping pamphlets in saying,
you know,
we may be doing something in this area,
uh,
you know,
all the good guys leave and stuff like that.
You know,
cy upset a lot to play with that or chopper's going around with their speakers
and you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So yeah,
that particular one,
there was another group of boats I went up ahead of us,
dropped off their guys,
the ninth infantry and were coming back and we passed him.
And as soon as we got by him,
I'd say about 10 minutes and we got opened up on,
they didn't hit the first group,
they just hit our group.
And uh,
you know,
that was a,
that was a bad day in dodge city,
but you know,
you got hit really bad but you managed to get to the shore and put some of the
guys off and stuff.
And it was,
I think it was going to be a pincher movement where they came in.
Okay.
People,
cause they dropped the other guy's way off and there were three Udt guys on that
group.
And then there were three of us on the group that when we got done,
he had,
and your main mission was going to be demo if basically yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
uh,
those,
those big,
it's weird.
Those are like straight up amphibious operations.
The army's conducted.
Okay.
Now think about that.
And the Marines are holding the DMS.
Yeah.
You were saying that the marines were busy upholding the DNC at that time.
That kind of blew me away that the,
but the ninth infantry did a good job.
I mean,
they were fighters,
you know,
and they were out of Washington state of Washington,
and uh,
they,
uh,
they were good,
good troop.
Yeah.
Um,
what about,
uh,
another different difference?
I mean,
even with the ninth infantry,
those guys,
I mean in Udt you guys are all volunteers and I mean,
and you've said you would have been drafted and had you not joined.
What did you,
did you notice any difference?
Okay.
Between drafted guys and guys that were volunteers?
Yeah.
Didn't really work with that many army guys in the ninth infantry.
The only thing I can remember that stands out as,
I had a second lieutenant come up to me when was on a river boat,
one of the river boats.
They were about ready to land him.
And he came up to me with his map and asked me where he was,
you know,
oh.
And that kind of,
I went,
hmm,
that's a second lieutenant.
She's leading a platoon or squad or guys in,
you know,
they kind of,
you know what I'm saying?
I just don't know.
I don't know.
My thought of that was,
is we were trained and we knew what we were going to do,
just like in seal team and we leaned forward and that's what we're going to do.
You're just picked off the street,
go through basic training,
and then you,
uh,
you know,
next thing you know,
you were up on a hill,
Vietnam being over random stuff that's gotta be pretty traumatic,
you know.
But then again,
Americans are Americans.
We fight,
you know what I mean?
Regardless,
but I think we were more psychologically set for what we did.
Then you're,
because of the extra training we had and stuff,
plus the guys that trained us where a lot of more Vietnam guys and like I said,
Second World War in Korean.
That gives you with the type of job they did and that that's what we do.
You got wounded on that vision too.
Yeah.
Right.
How bad did you get wounded?
Yes.
Some shrapnel on my foot and my leg.
No big thing.
Did you,
did it take you out of the field for an amount of time at all?
In fact,
I got up and started shooting along this guy,
this other guy,
we had this,
a buddy of ours,
I think I told you this,
he got hit really bad,
was rapping on his arms and legs and I called over to him after I moved my
fingers and toes and everything and realize that we all got blown down and then
uh,
went over to him and hitting him with morphine,
putting it through its color.
Then the 30 gunner got blown off his gun.
So I got up there and started shooting a 30,
you know what I mean?
No big thing,
but it's just what you do.
You know,
we're in a hurry.
So you shoot back.
He got blown on the other side of him and calls over to him,
didn't see my pin through his collar.
So hits him with another shot of morphine,
you know,
and about four or five minutes he kind of set up like this and wanting to do
something.
But he was,
he was screwed.
He was hurt really bad and then got up and started shooting and stuff.
And the guys that were down in everything,
we're after the 30 ran out of Ammo.
I started shooting sixteens and they hand us up.
Sixteens is shooting stuff,
load them for us and shit.
And then like I said,
the ramp went down and we started going in towards the beach to let the guys
that weren't,
uh,
wounded,
get off.
And we started taking fire right through the front.
So I went to one side,
you went to the other side and I was using uh,
uh,
m 79 to try to suppress fire and stuff.
And then we backed off and then we got out of there.
Did you insert any of the army guys?
Yeah,
about eight or nine of them,
you know,
and how big,
how many guys got inserted?
I was like a company or a company strength.
Yeah.
Not,
yeah,
it was more than a company who was eight bolts a lot of people about you can put
about 25,
30 guys on the boats.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we were here.
We,
like I said,
it was really a weird thing cause uh,
you know,
we're sitting there and then everything just started fire going
off and we heard a number one boats hit.
We're number four bolt [inaudible] number three,
number four.
Yeah.
Number two,
boats hit number three boats hit.
And I remember I just turned and looked at it and said,
we're fucked.
And we got hit.
And what it did is it has a canvas cover and they had all those wires stretchers
stacked up in the beef.
40 rocker was heading right towards the uh,
uh,
the
conning tower,
you know what I mean,
where their driver and everything,
but it went low and hit those stretchers and he just went,
you know,
all that shit went out.
So
did you guys get good medical training?
I mean obviously you had to give morphine.
Well Udt yeah,
pretty good.
Yeah.
But in the seal team we had extensive dental,
medical training factor.
First platoon I went over as a,
we had our first class Korman.
Okay.
Probably the best.
Every week he had run a sue,
something rather was soggy head wounds or something,
sucking chest wounds.
And we had the same stuff that you guys did a have the mannequins up in the
woods and you'd have to run up and treat him and what to do.
And we uh,
learned to give ourselves a serum albumin them in case the corpsman was hit or
seven,
you need to give yourself an ID.
We did all that stuff.
Yeah.
All of us carry that with us.
Everybody had Seroquel Beaune them,
which is a blood volume expander,
you know what I mean?
Just in case you had to have it.
But uh,
Udt not so much.
We knew morphine,
we knew the basics,
some of the basics and you know,
pressurize and tourney kits and stuff like that,
but not real,
real good.
And UTS,
they do a good job with that t triple c class that they teach now.
Africa,
you forget what it stands for,
but it's good combat trauma.
You guys learn that.
And so they know what to do when somebody gets hit.
Everybody in the platoon knows like a decent amount to get.
The guys stabilized
told us in a platoon,
this is the one in 69,
he says,
Ya,
yeah,
I'm the only Corman here and if I get hit,
somebody's got to take care of me
through extension.
Good for him.
So,
uh,
you get home from that deployment and now like you said,
you,
you knew you had enough of the naked warrior,
your stuff and you said,
I want to get a big machine gun.
But I will say that was one of the best deployments I was on the guys and
everything.
The a Udt 12 at that time was comprised of class 40 41 and 42 and some are 43
but everybody knew everybody.
You know what I mean?
It was real tight and real good.
And Subic Bay who would put Guam to change oil?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Like I say,
after we'd been there for about three weeks,
you're ready to go to a,
yeah,
their debt just to get out of there.
He didn't go to Vietnam to stay pretty much.
No,
I didn't.
I never realized that you guys would go back to uh,
you know,
back to Subic Bay in the middle of deployments.
That's,
that's kind of how well we,
for
then you'd hit it off to your next year.
Like you said,
we were there for nine months in each debt was about three months,
you know what I mean?
Maybe a little less,
but we'd have some downtime and see we can,
then we'd go over Jordan next debt,
which is pretty nice.
You know,
nine months is a long time,
but still,
you know,
then actually back in the day,
Subic Bay was almost worse than Vietnam and some areas because a,
it was almost like the gangsters back in Chicago.
You had all these uh,
different gangs where after each other and shit mean when you're was walking
down excise a,
you almost had to look around the corner to see if,
you know,
they were shooting at each other for your walk by and Shit.
It was,
uh,
it was pretty,
kind of like the wild wild
you said that the whole Udt uh,
12 at that time was made up of all guys from the same like five or six buds
classes
that were there too from the other classes.
But it was,
uh,
the majority of us that were put into little platoons and suffer from class 40,
39,
maybe three,
and I was ahead of a they mode.
A lot of them went down.
Some went to 12 too.
They used to just put them in 11 and 12.
You went to a Udt team,
right.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
there are a lot of more guys that were behind us.
But remember we only ran two classes a year in bud.
Oh no kid.
Yeah.
Two classes a year.
Yeah,
we get 39 was graduated
and then we started 40 and then we graduated and that's when 41 was starting.
You know what I mean?
What do they run now?
Like five.
Yeah,
something like that.
Five,
six years,
something like five when I went through.
Yeah,
I think so.
So
you had a good experience with Udt,
but you still wanted to oh yeah,
I've got to go come man.
And we've put it into cit every month to go to seal team when they yelled at us
and said,
yeah,
not until you get back,
you know?
So when we got back,
we were the first two out of Udt into Cadbury.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
You know,
echo and I had a conversation,
I'll talk about how at seal team one when I was in training self silting one we
called ourselves cod dre and I didn't really know where that came from but I
knew that that was what it was called and we were proud that we are cadre.
But then I was listening to the podcasts that you,
you came on and you were talking about copy and you guys actually called the
cadre training.
That's what it is.
Qt was was cloudberry
guys that taught her were Kadri instructors and that just carried on.
I guess you don't tune training was different.
You know,
once you got in your gut out to ask you to your cadre,
then you went to a platoon,
then you went through platoon turning to,
and that was still ran by some of the contrary.
On the contrary we can,
cause we had our own training,
so on team one team,
one training cells been around that long though.
It was,
you know,
yeah.
That was the only team.
That's true.
And it wasn't another team that Udt guys and seal guys.
Yeah.
That workup or the cadre training.
Now you started getting heavy with field craft with,
I mean,
oh everything.
Yeah,
all every ambushes,
you name it.
And then we had the Lmo river we worked on and the [inaudible] was a lot like
Vietnam.
They actually set up a whole thing there to look like a Villi.
Jay had a little wooden outpost where that,
you know,
the whole nine yard,
you didn't have to work,
you'll go down,
get in and then work your way in and stuff.
And it was just like Vietnam.
It was pretty close.
And once again,
the people that are teaching you RF seals that are in Kadri now who'd probably
just got back from Vietnam,
so they got fresh
information from the backyard,
but tune train our training tone t one every time it platoon came back,
they had pull two or three of the best guys from that platoon and put them into
our training.
So,
and that was every platoon that came back,
they did that.
So he had a cross cut of all the different areas of Vietnam and guides that had
been in there that did well.
And that that's who we had guys like just some great guys.
I mean we got good training and I mean,
there was no bullshit because they knew,
we knew that what we learned there was going to save our asses in our buddies.
But so we,
we,
uh,
got pounded into our heads.
We did river and stream crossing of a lot because you had a lot of rivers and
you know,
small canal,
well not small canals has been pretty good size either walked on number one up
there to the side or you want to cross them,
you know,
like as a 60 gunner,
I always carried about three,
uh,
UDTs with me to help me fold across.
But I'm just saying,
yeah,
to judge the current.
Right.
So when you went out it would bring you right in where you're supposed to be and
stuff like that.
You know what I mean?
Just uh,
extensive training.
The Alamo on rivers,
not real.
It's not a real fast moving stream,
but it has a good current in it.
So you learned all that,
you know what I mean?
All you learned what you had to have or your gear you had.
Like we'd do a swimming cool stuff with our sixties and shit to see where we
needed to have the flotation and stuff like that.
You know what I mean?
It was pretty good actually.
When I went out to Niland,
we didn't even have the camp out there.
We had a,
in Niland itself,
the town there was a gas station and it had about four or five green little
green trailers and that's where we stayed at.
And then they use a truck is up to where the canal was,
the shooting stuff.
And a lot of times we'd go up there,
then we'd run back and stuff,
you know what I mean?
And we'd go up to the chocolate mountains up to,
um,
uh,
bill wells and stuff like that for ambushes and just,
you know what I mean?
We had an old camp.
There wasn't no camp there.
Psiphon,
what was that cipher?
I can't remember the siphon that I don't know.
I mean all along that whole area.
In fact,
later on,
whereas amplitude,
if we'd be going to chuck mountains,
come back some other way and you'd still see holes were 40 Mike Mike had went
into and stuff,
you know,
from back in the how much,
how much work were you doing at night?
Oh,
that's all.
The only time we weren't,
we do our immediate action drills and stuff during the day and stuff,
but all of our ambushes and all the other field craft that we did and everything
was all at night because that's when it worked.
And that was the,
that was the known thing.
It was like,
Yep,
we're going to go out at night.
That's what we do.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
How much did you guys,
did you guys go out if there was a full moon,
would you go out less in Vietnam?
Would you go out less if there's a full moon because you didn't fully June
stuff,
you couldn't see that.
Well it was still dark enough.
Cause sometimes there's a desert,
a full moon.
It's almost like data.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And what you know,
you're talking about gear a little bit and what you carried and there's all
these kind of myths about what guys were doing back in the day.
And in Vietnam one of them is blue jeans.
Like everyone wore blue jeans or a lot,
a lot of guys wore blue jeans,
which kind of makes sense to me because they're tough.
Right.
That was the whole reason was that mosquitoes wouldn't go through them.
And if you're in mangrove and stuff it wouldn't tear him and stuff.
Ripstop would tear.
And if you've been down like when you stopped and stuff,
excuse me,
each of live right to the rip stuff and stuff.
So we started wearing the blue jeans and you wanted to get zip up blue jeans,
not the button up cause they also kept leeches.
If you had the button button button up ones you were screwed.
And then sometimes we wore panty hose underneath that to keep leaches office.
But we'd take the Levi's and put them into our jungle boots and riggers tape
them around.
So,
you know,
we did,
it wouldn't just be hanging down where shit could come up and stuff.
There were a lot of leeches over there.
No big thing.
But I mean you just,
you just learned,
you know.
And like I said,
the penny hose,
it's pretty funny cause when we were on see float guys would be walking around
with pink and blue and yellow pantyhose on and stuff and sailors are given us
kind of some weird looks and shit.
You know,
it's kind of funny.
How about guys going barefoot?
Well we had a couple guys that do that and guys stepped on stuff and a injured
themselves and that,
uh,
I didn't see that very much at all myself in my platoons.
Maybe other proteins or tell you.
Yeah,
that was a big thing.
But a lot of times we don't walk on trails.
We walked outside of the trails and then there's all kinds of shit in there and
you don't want to,
uh,
just be bare for it,
I guarantee.
Yeah.
So you get done with that,
um,
workup and everything.
How about,
how about like your,
your,
you are pick gunner hired stories about guys taking every round out of their
belt and lubing every individual round.
Especially stone.
I heard that about stoner gunners that they'd take every round out of their belt
and lube every individual round and put it back in there.
Is that not true?
I've
never seen that happen.
And then we had four guys that carried the stoner machine gun and my last
platoon.
But uh,
I don't know why you'd take him out and put them back in.
They jammed a lot,
but that was just a stoner thing.
We send our guys to a Cadillac Gage,
which is who made the stoner so they can learn all the
intricacies and,
and uh,
what to do if something happened,
you know what I mean?
But the pink gun,
the 60 didn't have to worry about it that much.
As long as you took care of that baby,
it did work for you.
The only time we ever had a malfunction was operator error.
You know,
like having a slide down your arm and then you get a link stuck in there or
you're shooting it and year you have your doo rag around your neck and it gets
caught and started dragging
things you learn.
You know,
I don't know who told me the little one,
little one of Vietnam a seals told me this story that like you had the,
the um,
he had,
he was a stoner gunner and when he came back he checked in his weapon and he was
going and joining another platoon.
So he went to get,
uh,
a new stoner.
We're not a new stoner,
but one of the stoners out of the armory.
And he got,
went and checked the stone around of the armory and all engraved in the
buttstock of the stoner.
It said everybody must get stoned,
which I always got a good kick out.
It could have been no,
it was a,
but that 60,
it was just,
um,
and you developed exactly,
uh,
like my basic loaders,
about six 30,
because we had 130 a round box and we had China Lake made.
That goes,
went right on the side of it and we slung it,
you know,
on the shot from the hip.
But after shooting thousands of rounds from,
from the hip,
you get really good eye to barrel coordination of exactly where they're round
was going to go.
But even regardless,
you always worked at the end because it wasn't a uh,
excuse me,
a point weapon like a m 14,
you know,
it was a,
it's an area weapon but still you can get pretty accurate with that son of a
bitch and you always walk you around Jim because Wa rounds get Shane off kid hit
a guy just as well as get him right square in the chest or something.
And um,
I use canteen pouches and carried a five campaign canteen pouches around my
waist and I put a hundred rounds in there and leave about an inch out of that.
Got It.
Then when I would fire and I knew I was getting low pop,
my little on my uh,
can,
I had grabbed my,
uh,
thing of my 60 rounds snap men and dump them in and close it or the lid when it
opened up,
had ridges on the side and it would slide right in.
Just dependent,
you know.
But what was good about that box as you could be blown upside down or anything
and still have that hundred and 30 rounds are ready to shoot.
You know what I mean?
That's why we liked it.
But this place,
uh,
it was then,
it's a navy experimental place called China Lake,
can we,
so we had them build them for us and they worked really well.
Did you use a sling?
Yeah.
[inaudible] what we did is we took the big bud played off,
put an aircraft I played on and if you knew us in the back,
you have that round thing that,
and we'd take a hook to see that bringing it up and took a hanger and made it
down rule like this.
And I it around the front of the
hangar.
So you could take it off when you're in a chopper,
she can hold it down and then you can take it off,
put it on.
But you got to fit just right where it was just right,
exactly where you wanted to do.
And it worked great.
You know,
we were invented flux man.
We figured it out,
you know,
like we was on this one bolt one time and we saw these uh,
60 guys.
They were,
uh,
they had sixties and the bolts,
you know,
and they had these big metal containers that the rounds when and where to let
them in it.
Then it was a flex tube that went into the 16.
So a couple of gay bars later,
we walked off with a couple of those and they were fit perfect in the back of a
brick 77 a backpack.
We can put them on held 500 rounds.
And you had the flex tube that went right into your 60.
You had to have a special feed Tori for them.
You know what I mean?
It would feed trade the uh,
the feed tray was right on the end of the flex tube.
So it's set right in there.
Perfect.
So,
and then if we're doing an off the chopper charged a bunker off,
you had to have 500 rounds right there.
And it was kind of neat.
We're the only ones Vietnam that he had that in fact we came off choppers one
time.
We're doing parakeet ops.
I tell you about that later in,
uh,
there was a whole bunch army guides and stuff where we landed with the choppers
that are getting off,
beaten each other on the back and a couple of good firefighters and Shit,
you know,
and just another quarter light coming up and everything.
We're all bearded and you know,
Levi's and the,
all that shit.
Nah,
they're saying God damn.
I told you I had mercenaries over here was a mercenaries and one guy says and
all that seals.
So you guys,
you guys are the originators of the Predator pack pretty much I think.
I think we were,
they use them on the bolts but not on a,
not out in the field.
And you couldn't control it and I have to feed it.
No,
if fed itself itself right on the bottom of that folder,
no,
nothing.
It just right through there.
But you gotta be careful because if you took that thing off and laid it down and
didn't put a nail through the,
uh,
through the flex part of it all,
your rounded come out.
So they have this big pile of underground that's not good,
you know,
especially if he's in a firefight and stuff,
trying to put it back in,
you know,
I'm just saying just funny,
but it was a,
it was pretty good.
Me and a guy named two of us had those and we fixed them up just,
just playing,
looking at and thinking,
hmm.
But you couldn't patrol at night with them on patrol because they would go
clank,
clank.
You could hear her in my move.
And that was only if you're actually going off and hip and sub.
Like you say,
there was three types of ops we'd go into if we were going to take care of
these.
One was a downed pilot and um,
uh,
another seal platoon in trouble and a bright light was bright light.
That's a prisoner of war going into hit there and get them out.
But those three ops are the main,
main three woody went into no matter what.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Um,
you get,
so you finish your workup and
now you're over,
you go.
Your first deployment of Vietnam was this key low.
Yeah.
Kido Caleb
tune Vietnam.
And you're saying you were doing the first podcast,
you were saying that you did dart board operations,
which was have a guy huck a dark cause you guys that didn't have good intel,
you didn't have good
what we were,
we were at a place called [inaudible] and it was a Vietnamese Firebase out in
BFE gypped,
you know,
and uh,
we are here.
Then down here you had the river and see flow where other squad was.
But our squad got put up here.
That was
so just one squad out there by itself.
Yeah.
Oh Dang.
With the vid Vietnamese guys,
they had a fire base here and there was not good intel.
So you basically would throw a dart at the dart board and then do what?
Go do an ambush,
their go set an ambush,
basically go out and look,
set up ambush or something and see what was out there and patrol.
Yeah.
And that then you also were inserting primarily on,
on sand pans during that time.
It pretty much other ways.
We about three times we walked out of the Firebase and walked back in and that's
just,
that doesn't give you a warm and fuzzy,
you know,
cause a change guards and stuff and you come back in all Lacey's moving out
there and maybe they don't know what the [inaudible] is for your coming back in
and shit.
And you know what I'm saying?
So yeah,
we didn't do a lot up at new NAM can because of that.
And we only had sand pants.
We didn't have any of our bolts up there and none of the mediums or lights or
anything.
So,
uh,
after we'd been up there for about a month,
I think month and a half.
Then they brought us maybe two months and then they brought us down to see float
and then we start doing something
good ops down there.
How big is the sand pack?
How many guys could you fit in it?
Oh four or five.
So you take two band fans cause we were heavy.
Yeah.
Wouldn't take 2 cents to sand pants if you ever gotten into a sampan no,
they're not a real stable.
Both
Vietnamese are good to them because they're small.
But you get about five big Americans in there and it's a,
you have to be real careful.
And Are you rowing it?
No.
It's got a little motor on the back.
Yeah.
The little lights that of Ghana with us.
We can put it along with it wasn't just herself,
you know,
and then,
and then someone who had stayed with the boats.
Yeah.
The going to come back and get us,
you know,
but you didn't start working a lot until you got to see flow and what kind of
ops we do now.
See Float,
no,
same thing,
uh,
ambushes and going up wherever,
setting up ambushes.
And that's when I told you I think it would,
you know,
I get a little bit confused sometimes on pbrs and swept.
I'm thinking they were pbrs that we're down to the seafloor with us,
but they would,
uh,
we'd go up on the PBR and have a Boston whaler where this in a Boston winter can
probably hold four or five guys,
you know,
plus the guy on the front with a 60 and a girl.
The guy driving it.
Well,
the way we had worked at us,
we had the whole platoon there.
One platoon,
it'd be going to do something.
Well,
two guys out of the other,
I mean a one squad go up and two guys from the other squad luckily got to pick
to be the uh,
driver sitting up on a thing driving the,
uh,
the uh,
Boston Weiner and the other guy in the 60s,
while everybody else was just looking over the edge like this and it didn't get
your,
again,
it wasn't,
you didn't get real excited when you were chosen to be the,
uh,
the Coxen,
you know,
how often would you guys make enemy contact when you guys go out on ambush?
Cause I had to be kind of like looking for a needle in a haystack,
right?
Yeah,
we do
got some contact.
That was the one down in the square bay I told you about when we hit the,
when I wasn't on that up,
when they hit that junk and then older mother flares start popping up and they
realize and,
and a few other times we got into some,
uh,
some crap that particular,
that,
that platoon and that deployment wasn't,
we didn't do an awful lot.
We went out a lot or get me wrong,
but we didn't get in a lot of firefights and stuff.
It was my second platoon where we kicked ass.
And it sounds like,
I mean this is sort of classic and you and I were talking about this earlier
today.
If you don't have good Intel,
get fifth ambush all day long.
The float,
we didn't have that good of Intel,
you know,
and like we didn't have a chief of a platoon.
We had an Lpo and uh,
no mention of any names,
but he wasn't real good.
But we had this other guy that chief Korman had told her,
I'm not cheap at that.
A corpsman,
it was a first class and he kind of took over everything.
He had been with the Marines twice to Vietnam.
So he was a good hand,
you know what I mean?
Had a shift together with smart and just a couple of funny things happened when
it was down in the sea floor.
I told you where that pilot of close moved and stuck to set up all you're
looking for me.
We thought we had lost him,
you know,
and that was like the chopper comes in and lands,
two of them did and one was pretty shot up and door gunner had been hit.
So they said,
hey,
uh,
anybody want to be a door gunner?
We got to go back and pick up some other guys.
Well of course as a corpsman.
Yeah,
I'll go.
So he's in UDTs,
he throws a flak jacket on the Hellman and takes the door gunner position,
you know,
and they take off and about half hour later the chopper comes back in and lands
shot up even more hair.
He gets off the,
I mean,
uh,
he gets off the boat holes,
his helmet down,
takes his flat jog out.
Fuck on.
Ever do that again.
Yeah,
those,
uh,
we,
when we had,
um,
this guy Kirk colonel,
colonel reader on who's a pilot in Vietnam,
you flew cobras and Vietnam and a second deployment.
But those guys,
those pilots in Vietnam,
the helicopter pilots Vietnam's they did not,
they knew they were going to take grounds.
They just went in anyways.
They were bad ass.
Same
as our sea walls.
And the black ponies business,
he will especially were just unbelievable guys.
You know,
they were just bad ass dude demand and the uh,
and I,
I told you I wanted story again and I bought that one chopper.
So we're kind of pin down behind this rice die.
We're getting some pretty heavy fire from the uh,
tree lines.
So we call in for a closer support and it's the sea walls,
you know,
so we're getting up shooting,
getting back down my 60,
and we're getting kind of low on Ammo to except the seawalls.
We always had animals stage on the seawall so he could kick it off to us when
they came in.
So the seawalls are coming,
we can hear the roller of Walter.
Oh well when the sea wolves were doing,
they were the greatest when they weren't doing a close air support that do psy
ops,
they had these great big speakers.
So we hear this one sea wolf coming in behind us and we're still shooting
everything.
All of a sudden out of the clear blue sky,
I swear to God,
you hear this,
we are,
the gods are hell fire.
And we bring you flyer and the fucking rocket went over,
her head hit the tree line and they either had a 50 or a mini gun on one side of
the sea wolf and that sea wolf turn like that and just holds the down.
I think that one had a mini gun on and then right behind and came another seal.
But when they,
when we heard that we are like,
everybody just stopped shooting and we looked back up like,
what the fuck?
It was unreal and that's really suppress a fire.
So then the black bone,
they had 2.7 rockets and a black ponies came in with a five inch zoomies and
when they hit the hit the tree line,
it was blown to shit,
cleaned up over her head and that pretty much quotes to we've done and it'll get
out of there.
Just see lords came in the regular Hueys that picked us up and got us out of
there.
That was,
that was a good off though.
The Wolf's where the Navy pilots,
Navy Vietnam gun ships that came and supported and we're in like cobras.
They were regular [inaudible] rep with the rocket pods and I think,
uh,
like the,
black ponies had the 20 millimeter guns in the front and then the five inch
zoomies they had the,
just the rocket pods,
but they had a 50 on one side and or a,
uh,
mini gun on the other side.
And the most important that they think that they had from everything I've heard
and from what you're telling me right now is they had balls.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
they're good.
They were just come in and we got drunk one night or bar seawalls are on the
army side.
That's where they had their thing.
So we figured,
hell,
we'll go over and visit him and have him drink with it.
So we jumped in our six by and headed out.
We were,
they had the army base here and the navy base.
Here we are,
lived on the Vietnamese side and had her own own very soul to fight.
It was perfect.
We,
anyway,
we got an r six pine was heading out when over where the Seawolf guys where we
want to drink with us.
You know,
we had our sixties was stuff you never knew,
you know,
so we'd get over there and go walk in and their compound everything.
All right boys get up,
let's drink.
Well see we made them drink or this naked cause we were all naked so we're all
sitting there drinking beers,
naked
nakedness and sixties and booze.
I like where this is going.
You guys had way much more fun in Vietnam the morning time.
I'm telling you,
we weren't a,
we,
we'd get back to a knop dewar debrief cleaner weapons and go up and get shit
faced.
You know,
criminal readers said the same thing.
He goes,
he goes,
yeah,
you know we'd go out,
we'd fly,
we'd get shot up,
we'd have to come back and like put the birds in for repair.
I then we'd get drunk and then we'd go and he goes,
I don't know.
He really like looked at me and he said,
I don't know how you guys did it without alcohol.
Basically you're going to say,
yeah,
that was it.
You know,
went to Desert Storm.
We were over there nine months and no alcohol and stuff.
It was okay.
But I mean,
to me it was just like,
yeah,
this isn't my war.
You know,
we really didn't do that much.
And you know,
the guy did recons and stuff from Michelle hub and we did that one deception up
and uh,
when we inserted the Kuwaitis and that's outside of that,
they never would have gotten to a firefighter
this shit,
you know?
Yeah.
That was,
I'm assuming that was on your second deployment was your first,
your first appointment,
you know,
you did what you did,
but it wasn't as fruitful.
No,
I'd get it to me tell you the honest to God truth.
Coming out of 18 to seal team,
I was ready to hit the deck running and it just seemed like we didn't hit the
deck running over there and just didn't have the Intel I don't think are,
as you were saying,
leadership was all that good and stuff.
I mean,
we had one guy,
the Lt,
they were doing some shit down in sea float,
but if where we were,
we just didn't,
you couldn't,
it was just wasn't that much you could do,
you would go out and look,
try to find shit and everything,
but we didn't have actionable intel that we can react on.
You know,
what you found out later.
That's what you have to have
sometimes too.
I think people spread their forces to thin.
Like you think about it,
you just take a squad and put them out there in the middle of nowhere with no
intel support and then you got another squad in some other area with no intel
support.
You know,
you might as well bring them together,
put a couple of guys together,
Intel and you start making something happen the platoon before.
So that was there.
And so that,
uh,
that was
put tune.
Rosie has gotten a lot of shit,
you know what I mean?
That's when he got his medal of honor and stuff like that.
And uh,
actually my second trip over had been in that book tune,
you know what I mean?
And told me some stories about it.
They got in a lot of shit that we were stuck in new NAM can and just didn't well
shift,
right.
You could see the human force,
which was at the very southern part of Vietnam and it's just triple canopy.
Just,
I mean we were away from that a little bit,
you know,
but the sole Vietnamese guy there,
he had tattoos all over and I guess he had fought with the French against the
Vietnamese Viet men,
you know,
which was the bad guys fighting the French.
Same as VC and we're through an interpreter.
We were talking to him and then I got damn human for us,
you know,
that's uh,
he says,
yeah,
a whole uh,
uh,
company of a French Foreign Legion.
Paratroopers jumped in there and none of them ever came back out.
And we're going
plus the way I,
that's when I was telling you in my last podcast I did,
that's where we landed and we're just starting to put her shit away.
And the sloths lands and it's approved visor and good friend of mine,
real good friend of mine now.
And then when that loach took off,
we got the ship mortar now for about two hours.
And that's when we told him,
don't ever
come here again.
You know,
so now when you get back,
you get back,
you do another workup and well actually you got out for a little bit.
You come back in,
you decide,
you know,
that's like when I went to college,
I had to go to,
I had to get my,
once I got my commission,
I had to go to college and people would say,
oh,
what'd you learn in college?
And I'd say,
I learned in college,
never,
ever,
ever get out of the teams ever
deal.
So,
uh,
you,
you get out for a year or something and you come back in and getting your,
your second platoon and getting ready to go to Viet.
Was that November platoon?
Okay.
You're,
he just passed.
And what a great guy.
I mean,
was he the platoon commander?
[inaudible] it die?
We Ot,
you know,
he's a great guy.
Just a great guy,
man.
He,
uh,
and he just passed here,
about three weeks ago and we went up and Rosecrans and they buried him and
stuff.
But he was a great guy,
man.
And that workup,
that workup did,
it did,
did much change between your first workup at seal team and your second one
actually when I got out,
only came back in and went back through cadre.
Oh,
okay.
Just to kind of crush yourself refreshed had been about a year as out,
you know what I mean?
And it just,
it,
that's the way he did it in [inaudible] if you were gone way over six months or
something,
you went back through cadre is to even the guys that came from these coals,
you know,
just so they know how we worked in self,
which was good.
Why was going through cadre?
Jury Fletcher was out there with this platoon and they got to know him and uh,
I knew some of the other guys who have a teen.
So soon as I got out of the cadre,
they lost a guy in their platoon.
And lucky enough,
I was good enough to get into it.
So I didn't go through the whole workup with November two night,
just got in it.
And uh,
that's when I was telling you was down at the ream field.
They used to have a firing range down there.
And,
uh,
I was figuring out,
ma'am,
I shoot something else.
And I,
you know,
that's when I actually asked the first,
that's when I picked up a 60 me and this guy,
um,
we shot it,
this career,
saw log pieces,
flew off the Curtis whole log,
and we set it on fire.
And I remember looking at him,
you're looking at me and it was like,
we're in.
So that,
that was it.
Yeah,
the 60s a beautiful thing.
Oh,
it's a great thing.
So this next deployment,
and you mentioned this on the,
on the,
on the first podcast when you came on about the
orders that you got from,
was it from Mac resach?
Is that who you're getting orders from?
Four v Nav for V and we landed in Saigon and Rlt die.
We went up to,
uh,
to see where we're going to go.
Uh,
what area we're going to work in.
What province,
you know,
and he went up there and they told him,
well you got the Vin long province,
she is where Dong Tam is and stuff.
And he said,
uh,
his orders were to pacify it.
That was it.
And uh,
we brought,
uh,
he uh,
picked up a whole bunch of money so we can pay our kit Carson scouts and stuff
like that.
And we went to dawn cam.
Well we stopped at Ben.
Look first it's about 40 miles away from Dong Tam and there was another platoon
there,
Gary Gallagher's platoon.
We shows up in her six buys and stuff and we're kind of rugged looking,
cause we'd been in Saigon for three days and having a good time and shit and
comes walking out and he looks at us,
he goes,
God damn,
you guys look like you've been here six months already.
You always little be dragged ode to shit.
Then we went to Dong Tam,
but we used to go back and forth.
I was the Neptune George anger.
They just had some great guys and they were,
like I said,
they're our sister platoon,
you know.
So we'd go and see each other once in a while with the sister platoons deployed
at the same time?
No,
they had been over there for three months.
Okay.
So was it like a overlap of three months of the platoon?
Some of them,
yeah.
Two of them may go at the same time.
It usually when you got there,
there was another platoon somewhere around ya rather east coast or west coast of
course.
East Coast had two platoons over there.
So fung towel.
I'm thinking it was one cow got,
I'm still trying to think of that name.
It's a right on a river and that's where the east coast platoon was.
We never,
not bay,
that's where it was not be.
And that's where the east coast puts in there.
They had a platoon there and they had a platoon of Mito and that was their two
platoons and then we took over.
When they left,
we took over the one that dawn Mito,
but we moved to Dong Tam because we didn't want to be right in the middle of a
city,
you know,
or a big,
big town or a city.
So we moved down to Dong Tam and then the navy base didn't want us,
the army base didn't want us to,
they put us in the Vietnamese base that split them.
So there you go.
Yeah.
And that was good.
We had our bolts right there.
Everything was perfectly,
we go to the army base,
the test fire weapons and shit.
And they were doing that all the time anyway.
So it wasn't,
it's another thing.
I wonder how can we tell how they test fired their weapons and shit.
Anyway,
so what was your op tempo like when you are on the second deployment?
Deployment was a,
we'd go out about
every two to three days because you had to gather in tone and stuff like that.
And uh,
and then we'd get a little break.
And if we were real board,
we'd do what we called parakeet ops.
And,
uh,
there was this area,
I don't know if I talked about this in the first podcast,
but it was a place called the plain of reads and it was all enemy as all VC.
And so we'd take off,
uh,
four or five of us in a Huey didn't have a seawall from front and in back of us.
And we just fly out there,
start looking,
go over,
go over small hamlets and villages and a few CVC run around and get shot at.
They had land us,
we'd sweep through,
then they'd pick us up and we'd go look for some more,
you know,
that's when we were bored,
we call them parakeets pups.
And then the,
uh,
when we hit and started spreading around,
the Seawolf would go off.
I mean,
Not Sea Wolf,
the Sea Lord,
which was our Huey and then the seawalls and start circling,
looking for his quarters and stuff,
you know,
it was good.
We might get in two or three firefights you know?
Yeah,
I guess that would daytime off.
So you're just running those daytime ops and what you would you just look at the
map and say,
hey,
this is probably a good spot.
Yeah,
the planar reads a whole place,
uh,
strong stronghold,
VC strong goal,
a lot of VC out there.
So then that's when,
uh,
we took a couple of the Australian was us on that and those parakeet ops and
stuff and it blew him out of the way
or how they like it that they come back for more.
Oh yeah.
We had two groups come down to us than me and
well to Nui dat where the Australian they'll us where and when our them and that
was pretty,
pretty unique.
Yeah.
My 60 and route 500 rounds in 120 pound pack and walked around for about eight
days.
I was real happy about that.
It was good.
They were,
they were great troops and uh,
you know,
they loved coming down and working with us because we got contact and uh,
when they,
you know,
they're,
they look for things to see if,
what they could find.
They have two types of things.
They had a five man fighting patrol or a 10,
I mean a five man Ricky or a 10 men fighting patrol.
When we went out with him,
it was a 10 men fighting patrol cause we're going to go into this area that the
Australian armored infantry had taken over this,
uh,
north,
the Nva north Vietnamese army base camp and then just decimated it.
Well,
our job was to go see if any of the Nva had moved back into the area or none.
It was good.
The best.
Like I said,
my first podcast is the best reconnaissance guys I've ever,
ever worked with.
And their fighters too.
They're good,
good,
good troops.
Yeah.
For some reason a lot of people ask me if you've ever worked with foreign
troops,
everyone want to con kind of wants to know what we think of their countries and
their troops,
you know,
and uh,
the Brits and the Aussies vsts or top kill for sure.
The only ones that went out,
well,
those on patrol and I think we're in Vietnam.
We were the only ones that went out with them.
You know,
it all started out with a couple of SAS guys drinking in a bar with a couple of
our guys and pooper pats and tell him tall tales and you know,
drinking beers and shit and next thing you know,
we had this exchange and it's been
ongoing attendance.
Yeah.
Always.
When I was a team one,
there was always a SAS guy there.
Yeah.
Did you or did you,
when you went to go,
did you get to go to Australia?
Never went.
No.
Oh,
you'd love it.
It's great.
I always got a,
I always got screwed out of going Australia five times after Vietnam and hill.
There was show guys there that had been to Vietnam with from yesterday.
Sas.
You know what I mean?
It was good.
It was great.
Yeah.
I always got screwed for some reason.
I'd always go,
wow,
yeah,
we're going to go to Australia.
And some something will come up when we wouldn't get to go.
That's because your platoon officer wasn't very well liked or something?
Most likely.
What?
Uh,
when you said you were getting contacted a lot,
so you're doing an app every two,
three days.
How often are you guys getting an enemy contact?
Okay,
Jeff thought every time we went out because we were going out on actionable
intel,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
shit,
I can't think of all of it.
Like at one time I was telling you and another time we hit these two who,
and guys came out,
it was like the OK corral except we won.
And um,
another time where it's doing this re conscious looking and this one guy,
um,
or gets up on top of this bunker because we couldn't find any entrance around
it.
They may have had a tunnel coming into it somewhere and he's up there and I'm
standing here in this guy,
right?
She has a sixties there and we're kind of watching the area for him while he's
up there looking around and Q and Q and tune tune right by me comes as AK 47
rounds in the miss me.
I don't know how the hell they miss me,
but uh,
then,
uh,
jumps off the,
the bunker down right beside me and yeah,
just gone.
Yeah.
The guys over there,
that guys over there and meet her,
hear yelling and we'll shoot the son of a bitch.
Finally we saw where his rounds came in and we started shooting and another time
we got pinned down a little bit and we were going to go in and hit this a check
this hospital out and stuff.
When we got hit pretty hard and we had a pullback and now move out.
That might've been when we got pinned down,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh,
is that when you called them the seawalls?
Yeah,
yeah.
We called them and a few times,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's interesting because people think that every time you go out you're going to
get any me contact and you could see,
I mean,
your first appointment,
yeah.
It was rare that you'd get enemy contact does the second time.
It's a lot more often.
Yeah.
Like my first deployment to Iraq,
we got like,
I don't know,
like four or five firefights maybe.
And they were all pretty like not,
not really a big deal.
And then when I was a troop commander,
Normani did,
the platoons were getting into it.
All the guy I know almost every,
not every,
almost every,
but a lot of the times,
I mean,
a majority of the times there'd be,
there'd be shooting going on,
you know?
Yeah.
Carrie,
you,
I've talked to a lot of guys that were in your platoon,
in Ramadi and they,
uh,
they had follow you to the [inaudible] the hell if they had her,
they loved you.
So just letting you know you had a real good impression and you,
you were outstanding just telling you that.
That's for my guy,
you know,
talking to the guys on the ground drinking and stuff.
When your name comes up,
you know,
well,
they're drunk.
I guess that's,
that's the reason I'm just showing it.
It's like,
you know,
well those guys were,
those guys.
Did those guys actually,
nevermind.
They would,
they did,
they,
they did all kinds of stuff that was above way above and beyond the call of duty
for sure.
And uh,
God bless you.
Took it to them and that's what,
that's what you're supposed to do,
you know?
Yeah.
It was,
uh,
it was,
it was an awesome deployment.
Awesome deployment and forth,
working with awesome guys for sure.
We went out one time and uh,
we heard there was this cashier,
you know,
so,
but we did want people to know they were going out there.
So we got into a refrigerator truck and hitting the back of that until they got
close to where the cache was and we went out and dug it up and came back.
Just little things,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That was a neat off.
That's uh,
that it's good stuff when,
um,
when you get back from that deployment,
and that was the last November,
when was the last fully deployed to Vietnam?
Yeah.
Did you didn't get any,
you didn't go back to sue beck when you were a seal platoon?
Did you know that was like,
no,
you can stay there the whole time.
Yeah.
Did get two weeks or a week or two weeks?
I think of rnr and uh,
I think I went to Hawaii.
Okay.
And Thailand one time.
So supports your choice of going to Hawaii.
He's from Hawaii.
So Hawaii is the bad.
Nope.
That's kind of weird though.
Go into Hawaiian.
Everything is all quiet and peaceful and everything and you just come out of the
woods and you know,
after you'd been there for a while you're,
you,
you kind of want to go back.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
If I went to Thailand,
I probably would've stayed in Thailand has still been there now and I'd probably
be dead.
It gives a lot of people that go to Thailand and don't come back.
Bangkok makes the hard man humble can guarantee you
did a,
I remember last time we talked about this blue on blue that you guys had,
was that in November we'll tune?
No,
that was in kilos and kilos.
it was our,
the officer that was with us up in a new NAM can and that was like you said,
was supposed to be an air hammer and anvil off.
It just went wrong.
Yeah.
And I,
I'm not sure if he was,
uh,
stood up to shoot or if he was trying to wave and tell them to stop shooting.
Anyway,
he got hit,
you know,
killed him.
So,
and then we almost had another in November platoon,
or you forgot to mention this.
So we're hitting this island and it's not a big island,
but it had hooches all along one side.
So they wanted us to go through and check out the hooches and we had what we
called white mice with us.
They were Vietnamese Intel guys.
I could look through things and find out if there's any VC stuff,
you know what I mean?
So thing.
So we lands and were sweeping through it.
And I had this one white mice with me and I had my 61 of the guy that
plan this hop and thought it was a good idea was our debt golf guy and the debt
golf was your senior seal,
was that Def Golf?
And he was kind of in charge of all the other ever spread out.
And um,
so we did it and he was with us and his interpreter.
So,
and we were told everybody stay on this side when we patrol,
because anything on the left side is a free fire zone.
Right?
So we're walking along and I'm looking at it,
the woods and I'll say,
see this Flint and through the woods.
So I bring my 60 up,
take it off as safe and I'm watching,
well where the woods,
where there was a space and then another part of the woods where I wanted the VC
who I thought it was to get out in the space.
And then at hammering,
you know,
open up with my 60 and a,
we're spread out a little bit because everybody was checking different things
out as we're going along.
So I had it off safe.
I'm just have laid it up on this a rice or rice bag,
you know,
with Rice on it and just waiting who comes out.
But the lieutenant commander,
the Ted Golf Guy,
I was so fucking pissed.
If I had been a new guy,
I'd open up,
you know what I mean?
Maybe killed him and a thing.
So I told Jerry Fletcher my auntie about it and he never went out with us again
because that was crazy.
He was under the free fire zone,
you know what I mean?
And like you say,
what if I'd been a brand new guy or something new,
but I wanted to wait til he got out.
So I had a clear picture before I opened up on him.
Yeah,
I mean even your mindset wasn't even,
let me confirm this as a bad guy.
You knew it was a bad guy.
You were just waiting for the him the,
I wasn't saying that he,
that might be one of our guys.
I knew it was a bad guy because we had already briefed heavily,
everybody stay on this side and anybody over there.
And you see them open up on them.
You know,
when I was running training man I,
I worked those guys,
they would have blue and blue is all the time in training.
I mean we would just make stuff so confusing and just put the enemy in the wrong
place and get guys confused.
I wanted them to have blue on blues and training so they realized how easy it is
to happen.
So you get a guy instead of making that decision like,
oh,
I'll just,
you know what,
there's probably get a good vantage point over here if I just walk over here and
they'll know it's me.
You know?
It's like,
no,
they won't know what you,
they'll kill you.
So yeah,
it's a man you got to,
people don't understand how confusing it gets out there,
man.
It gets confusing.
That's where you're training and you're like,
I was telling you though,
it saved our butts.
Vietnam was there immediate action drills and they have them so ingrained into
us that it's dark.
You know exactly where the guy is going to be and what you're going to do,
whether it's a peel off or whether you're going to the right or left.
You know what I mean?
Getting out of the,
uh,
the fire zone,
whatever,
you know what I mean?
But you had to have that man,
that was immediate action drills to me are the key no matter what you're doing,
whether it's urban or I think,
which I can't really,
no,
it's the same thing.
The same thing in an urban environment.
You got to have a mediator.
Say you have a hooch there and you're going to hit the hooch,
you know,
we know there's probably bad guys in it.
And then we're coming in.
What we do is two guys to branch out to the right or left to get anybody from
behind.
The restaurant would go in,
one guy would turn around and look that way and the guys would go in and that
way they could shoot,
you know,
um,
one 80.
Yep.
You know what I mean?
And nobody was down.
Now if the hooch was covered and had full of around it,
then as we came in,
one of the guys in the left or go down,
lay down,
looked behind,
the other guy would be right here at the corner so he could see anybody coming
out a window.
And then we'd have the other guy over here and then we'd go in and hit it.
But what I'm saying is when we did that,
it was like that.
I mean that and that was our immediate action stuff that we did.
That's how we'd hit a hooch.
And then when guys went in,
they had switch one swing high swing low just to,
you know,
to check it out.
Then they'd go through and then it's a clear or we got someone and then whoever
was right next to the door facing out,
cause we had our security,
didn't know if anyone but he was going to come behind you is that bring the guy
out.
Like I had my 60 I'd stick my 60 right between his legs and fold down than it
put my 60 in his mouth and go shit.
He wouldn't say much.
You know,
and we'd take off.
Yeah.
That,
that you were talking about how the Sas,
one time you went home,
show the SAS and they went out there,
you're out there for like 10 days and no one said a single word the whole time.
If you did say something you put here right next to the guy or your mouth right.
He actually was there and talk.
But normally it was all answering those.
But like what you're talking about,
all the stuff that you just described to do all that stuff without talking to
everyone just knows where to go.
It's,
it's a standard operating procedure.
It's the immediate action,
Joel and everybody knows exactly what to do and yeah,
that's
yes.
Like you get a booby trap or something,
the smartest thing to do is back away and come in in a different way.
But if you had to keep going,
you'd feel it with your hand and grabbed the guy next to you behind you and show
him where it was.
Then you'd step over,
move on a few steps,
wait til he got over it by grabbing the guy behind him and you just keep moving.
How often would you guys do that?
Not Too often.
We,
we did run into him occasionally,
but we were kind of lucky.
We never hit plus you'd see,
uh,
[inaudible] you'd be able to pick up the signs if you did happen to go on a
trail,
you could see broken branches facing a certain way or a little little sticks
pointing in a certain way or,
or actually we got landed one time in this,
a rice patty and we look after we got off,
everybody started looking around and all you could see was two doors signs,
which a man minefield.
So we didn't move,
you know,
we just call it the choppers back in and took off.
So your,
your second deployment to Vietnam,
how many casual,
how many cats does he,
no one got killed,
right?
No,
we didn't get anybody hit or killed.
No one got hit or killed despite getting in all of those gunfights.
Yeah.
Don't ask me which one of those things.
God's a frog man.
We figured,
you know,
we're getting to the point,
that's why we had six month deployments and not a year or you know,
whatever.
Cause uh,
you start feeling like you're invulnerable,
you know,
but we're on the cutting edge and uh,
we just had the firepower.
We were better.
I mean,
you could have the odd Jenna,
like that one,
the one that went right by me or something.
I could have hit me right in the chest or you had too much skill to get hit.
It wasn't skilled at pure luck.
Dude.
I know.
It's like a,
unfortunately in combat you can do everything right and you can still get killed
and he can do all kinds of things wrong and live.
We did that stay behind ambush that one night.
I think I told you about that.
I don't think so.
Okay,
so butter second op,
we had Vietnam thought we're going to go in and hit this one area here and if no
reason the uh,
the little village or anything like that,
then we're going to do a stay behind ambush.
And so a squad of us went in and patrolled through through some,
uh,
Willie Peter to hooches shit like that,
and just kind of caused hate and discontent.
And then the sun started going down.
So as soon as it's hard going down,
we've gotten an l shaped ambush being were rice patties.
We're going this way,
that way and stuff.
And then we had the other choppers came in like they were going to pick us up.
We had our other squad on it.
They got off the chopper ran around and got back in it like we're being
extracted.
Right.
So we sat there and sat there for about 45 minutes,
almost an hour,
Nelson here,
these guys come walking down this rice dock with AK 47 shit and stuff.
And uh,
we opened up on them and you know,
blew him off the rice dyke and shit.
And then they opened up on us from the treeline,
hit him a little bit to see what else came in and did some damage and shit.
And then the fucking chopper comes in.
There was only one of them,
so we'll all couldn't get on it.
We landed with two choppers,
you know,
so me and another guy,
a radio man,
and I'm a stoner guy myself stayed there.
Why that chopper went long.
Cam wasn't too far away.
Come back and picked us up,
you know,
and my poop was a little tighter,
tight on that and stuff.
How long were you sitting on the ground?
Oh,
about another 20 minutes before they can,
we got us.
But nobody came in to the village after that because we had,
we had hammered them that so,
and that was pretty good.
But that was a brilliant up.
Anyway.
So I'm shooting my 60 he's over here shooting the 40 Mike,
Mike,
and there's a small stream between us and we got back were drinking beers,
patent poopers dean,
you know,
tell him tall tales and she hasn't,
he says,
God damn,
didn't you see that fucking string around?
So went right by on the stream and I says,
no,
cause that's,
shoot my 60 you know,
it was pretty neat.
You know what I mean?
That's some good times over there.
Yeah,
that's,
that's an amazing deployment to do all that Jay behind ambush,
classic pure.
I mean just the way you want to do it.
They knew we were there,
they thought we'd laugh,
they came in and we got the son of a bitches,
you know,
and then they always say,
did your shooting Guy Yourself?
Well you know when you open up with stoners in sixties and you see guys flying
off a rice tax and shit,
you're not sure if it's her 60 that hit em or if it's a stoner or whatever,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's the only one time.
I know I hit a guy for a fact is that often that when we came off the choppers
and did that OK corral thing.
Well then me and a guy,
another guy went around the,
before the squad continued moving by,
we wanted to check out the back,
you know,
so you know,
it goes walking around and he had a car,
he was our Korman and I saw him walk around the edge and fire about three times
I stepped by,
he missed the guy and here's this guy with an AK 47 right about here.
And I stepped around with my 60 pointing right at him,
you know,
and I just flipped him.
And then we joined up and went,
kept going.
And then three guys popped up out of the rice dyke and one they started shooting
at us and we were shooting back.
But a sea wolf was coming right over us and three rounds went right through the
instrument panel on the Seawolf didn't hit anybody.
They turn like this and the guy had a mini gun and he just went on and we just
dropped down because there was fucking rounds going everywhere.
Yeah,
that's the amount of firefights you guys are getting into.
Take no cash.
We didn't.
That's amazing.
And we didn't have a lot of pictures either because we didn't have a
professional photographer walking around with it.
Yeah.
I mean it's a,
we missed,
I would say in Ramadi,
we missed the real,
like a couple deployments later,
maybe a year later when guys we're going on appointments,
they had pictures of everything because they had helmet cams and they had all
this stuff and we didn't.
And as a matter of fact,
at that time there was like rules against taking pictures.
So we don't have a bunch of pictures.
Both platoons I was in,
we took one just before we deployed and you know,
the whole platoon and then,
uh,
hardly nothing else after that.
We wouldn't let photographers close to us.
We wouldn't let a,
uh,
newspeople even come close.
We weren't a Vietnamese based thing where they couldn't get on it.
It was perfect and we just,
yeah,
we just went out and did her thing and had to get diamond.
Didn't beat no drums about it,
you know what I mean?
It was,
it was good.
Yeah.
There was a couple of platoons that had a photographer with him that took a lot
of pictures of shit and you probably,
you probably seen them and you know,
we didn't.
Yeah.
And there's platoons for in Iraq there was platoons,
it gotten Trump.
And that's one of the reasons why we didn't take pictures cause there was the
tunes that had pictures that got exposed and got released and they will,
shouldn't have,
they were pictures they shouldn't have taken and they got trouble and it not
just that they got in trouble,
but it was bad press,
bad press for America,
you know.
And uh,
that's why there was rules.
It was like,
Hey,
no pictures.
So we don't have a lot of pictures of him.
Right.
How to do a hundred things right.
And you do one thing wrong and that's what's going to pop up.
Yeah.
And you do one thing wrong and you take a picture of it.
Yep.
And these days,
you know,
that picture is going around the world in 30 seconds.
So it's a,
the desk.
One thing that has definitely changed and,
and like I said when we were in Ramadi,
we were just like,
I don't think people were really on social media yet that we know not everybody
had a camera and not everybody,
you know had a video can these guys got video cameras now that got helmet cams.
I got all this stuff and you know,
some of it's good,
some of it's beneficial.
I mean you're not going to get any better intel.
Then there was a,
a company commander from the first of the five or six who was one of the best
guys I've ever worked with,
but he videotaped every time he went out on patrol,
you know,
Humvee or,
or not in a Humvee.
However,
he was going on patrol.
He filmed the whole thing and he was working in one specific district of Ramadi
called the [inaudible] district.
And he would come back and watch those videos and he would just,
he and I sat there and watched him with them one time and he goes,
yeah,
you see this garbage can over here.
Yeah.
This,
this one's a good landmark cause it's a different color.
And then up on this street corn right here,
this is,
uh,
this,
poll is always filled with so many wires.
It always scares me,
you know,
cause there's so many wires hanging off it.
And he just had the whole city memorize because he had a camera rolling and his
home Humvee the whole time and for,
so for that reason,
plus when you gather intel,
you know,
you're going into a building and,
and you've got pictures of everything you got.
If anyone ever goes in that building gun here to here to here you go,
well here's what it is laid out.
So there's some definite benefits to it.
But yeah,
there's some real drawbacks as well.
If you know,
for people can use that stuff for propaganda against you.
Or if you're videotaping things or you're recording things that are going to
make,
you know,
the Americans look bad.
And now you're saying,
okay,
you did this.
Well,
here's what was happening in the situation.
Here's why this happened and here's the context.
Well,
the context isn't gonna make it on to youtube.
The only thing that's gonna make it on to youtube is the thing that makes
America look bad.
And that's what's going gonna so
that has got it.
And that's what the reporters are going to key on regardless of what you see.
We had barn dance files.
I tell you about that.
I think he did mention him.
Yeah.
Barden Dan files where this,
every time you went on an up and you came back,
the guy who was telling you was there intel guy or first class and uh,
we'd,
he'd fill out these barn dance cards,
like to call them barn dance.
Cause that's just the pro word for whatever or yeah,
but if they had the who where,
what,
and whys equipment,
anything we found out there,
what firefights we've got into what a [inaudible] with the enemy we're using.
Anything that would be good intel.
And it was just a five by four by five card.
But it was really good.
And every platoon like are the platoon we relieved already had theirs.
So if we're going back into a specific area that that went into,
we had it organized,
you know,
we'd look it up,
pull it up,
read and see what they hit and what they got and all that stuff.
And that would be help us out when we were going on and we did our briefs and
stuff and we'd do the same thing,
but every platoon who would have these barn dance files of what they did and the
areas they went into and stuff and it was pretty good,
you know,
that's how we did it.
You know,
that uh,
we didn't do the Camry quarter like you're saying,
but we,
anything that we saw that wouldn't be of interest of another patrol or another
platoon going into that area,
then we'd let them know,
you know,
through the barn dance files.
Yeah.
And then like you said,
uh,
when we got to
a Dong Tam,
Vinh Long Providence,
what did a split us up into provinces or districts in that province.
And then we would go out whether a kit Carson scouts or interpreter and gather
intel from the PSB guys.
The chiefs are from the SF that were out in the field,
indoor rangers that were doing fire bases and stuff like that and bring that
back.
And then we would put it up on our sip map and start working,
you know,
like,
uh,
we had this one,
um,
we knew through our,
our province at this one VCI which you've your high level guy,
they wouldn't transmit communicationwise they would bring your orders in and
packets,
you know what I'm saying?
And he would come through the province maybe once a month,
once every two,
all the different information to the VC,
what they want him to hit and stuff.
But he had all this stuff.
We knew he came through there every time,
but there were three different trails that he used because we'd gotten intel,
we didn't know which one it was,
you know,
so we went out on the one trail,
did an ambush wax and people and shit like that.
So we knew when the next time he came he wasn't going to do that trail.
And then we did the same thing on the other trail.
Right.
So we figured he's going to come down this trail.
And so we set up on him.
Got Him.
He came down that trail and we got him,
got some good Intel.
That's beautiful.
But that was just working with actual Intel,
trying to figure it out and,
and work in it,
you know.
So yeah,
work out real good.
Were you on that?
I've always heard about the software.
They wanted to get this one VCI and they ended up hitting like his,
his family or some member of his family.
And then when they went to the,
when they had the funeral they went and got the guy that
no,
I wouldn't have on that.
And there's a lot of things that happened and like you say,
when you're in your platoon,
that's Kinda your world and that stuff.
And I've heard of,
I don't remember hearing about that,
but I probably was one time and the trade winds,
the bar,
we used to drink the corn auto or something.
I'm sure that that was brought up.
Like I used to hit tax collectors and get their uh,
Piasta from him,
their money and then they would turn,
turn that into MPC and stuff,
you know,
just different things
collector because that's a,
that's a good thing.
You know,
I support PNF he had a whole bag full of money.
You will.
Oh well,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
No that's,
that's,
that's awesome.
That's a,
and it's all another thing that people,
you know,
it's all self generated.
So much of it is self generated.
Like when you're talking about,
it's the same thing for us.
I mean I had an intel group but my intel group was seals,
some Intel seals and some Intel guys and they created all of our Intel and you
know,
our guys fed into it and so we produced our own targets.
Kind of like what you're saying.
Yeah.
People have this thought that,
you know,
the assault force is sitting there waiting for some command to come down and go
hit this target.
But the reality is we're making
up the targets,
we're figuring them out ourselves most of the time.
Yeah.
Why can see the difference from my first book tune or we didn't have anything.
And my second platoon where we actually worked off of actually actionable intel
that we got,
it was like night and day.
I would do a whole different world and just like we talked about before we
started this,
you know,
you've got,
you're fine,
you've got your fix and then you got your finish and exploitation,
you know what I mean?
But that we're the best in the world I think on da stuff to finish.
But you can't do the,
the finish if you don't have the fine where you know what to go and hit,
you know what I mean?
And that's why long time ago we started up that field graph and all that other
stuff.
But
we are approved advisers.
We had a training site up in Quia Maca,
you know we called to advanced training and it was for approved visors because
they would go over there by themselves or with one of their American and have
about 50 VC,
whatever that they were in charge of.
And that proves actually were for when the CIA would,
could collect intel,
but they didn't have a method of going out and hidden that,
you know,
react on doing the finished part of it.
So that's when they started the [inaudible] program.
And then we had a provincial prevention recon units is what they were called.
Proofs we call improves.
Like you say,
if I throw out an acronym,
no,
I'm just making sure because I'm just so used,
you know,
anyway.
And they would pull a select guys to go through this prude training and east
coast guys too.
And um,
then they would go over and work for the,
said they'd be in charge.
You said VC,
but you didn't mean that rex VC vizio not,
not the act of guys that you avoid and stuff and decided they wanted to make
money,
you know what I mean?
So mercenaries is what they were.
And um,
so,
uh,
they had that train up.
Coy mean tree.
Does it mean turncoat?
What does it,
uh,
two boys.
A guy that,
yeah,
you left the uh,
the lead side or the Mba and went to Hawaii actually means no,
I don't the actual amount of it,
no,
I think it's a good,
it was a,
they'd put him in this camp and like when we went to Dong Tam,
we went to that camp with our interpreter,
but we just hadn't have a special boat guy at the time.
MST,
we call it a mobile support team,
not SBU that spoke fluent Vietnamese.
So we'd bring him with us when our interpreter didn't realize this guy could
speak Vietnamese to,
and then we'd start interrogating guys for our district that we're in,
you know,
for myself or Vinh long where the guys were and we had talked to them,
interrogate them and stuff and they sounded like they were good to go.
Then we'd bring him in as Care Carson Scouts and they would stay with us and
we'd let them go and stop at anytime we had an off.
They stayed with us until the op was done and stuff.
You know what I mean?
Then we just didn't let him go.
But they turned out that they were great guys.
And um,
anyway,
the proof program was about six months long and a half.
It was craft halfway was medical cause you had to have that when you're working
out there,
the medical especially cause you're on your own out there,
you know,
and you've got to be able to take care of yourself if she hit and um,
and then they would uh,
come over.
But these guys would also,
after they got done like we're going in,
another platoon would be able to get that is everything he did.
But we had about seven guys that are six guys.
It was one of them that went to a special school like Camp Perry,
but it wasn't camp here is different.
Was there a shorter version?
And they got that training and they're the ones that were the cadre for that
sat.
And like my first platoon in 69,
my whole platoon went through most of that before we deployed over.
So you get all that stuff.
We didn't get to field craft portion of it,
but they had some great,
really good,
uh,
quick killed trails and stuff like that and map and compass and everything.
You know what I mean?
And we're lucky cause the platoon every once in a while,
if they didn't have guys going through would be able to pick that up and go
through it.
But that was a superb training.
I mean really good.
You know,
that's,
yeah,
it all boils back to training all.
Yeah.
That's one of the best things about the seal teams and stuff.
They call them to advanced training or sat training specifically for the
prevention of recon units that they sent the guys over to.
Uh,
so when you got back from that deployment of Vietnam now,
like I said,
that was the November thing was the last full deployment to Vietnam.
And you now,
you know the wars kind of over,
but,
but you stayed in the teams.
Did you go right to buds?
I mean,
yeah,
that,
so I get these orders to the activity of space and I thought what the Shit,
cause that's when the dirty 30 was happy and all that.
So yeah,
I blame the [inaudible] the dirty 32 people now,
dirty 30 is where after the war we had too many people and they wanted to cut us
down.
So even though guy who just got out of trees and stuff,
they pick 30 guys to go out to the fleet fee,
divers,
ELD and stuff like that.
And after two years they could come back or whatever and it was just sucked.
It was just one of the low points I think of the teams.
Imagine you just made major,
made it through buds and or Udt training,
whatever they called her back then.
It might've been buds and next thing you know you're,
you know,
you're going to dive score somewhere anywhere.
I went over to and that was really pissed.
I went over to,
uh,
to um,
buds as an instructor,
land warfare.
It was a third phase and all that shit.
But,
uh,
they still had LDN program going on then,
which is,
uh,
we're uh,
you know,
gotten his action.
Some other guys did and I wanted to stay there and still do the LD and then I
figure,
I don't know,
I just was one was selected to go to buds.
Yeah.
Then when I got done with,
I went back to t one.
How long were you at Bud's instructor?
For two years.
Yeah.
And then you go back to t one.
I was there again for about seven years and it took about three or four
platoons.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
When you see Budz now,
cause you still are in the community,
is there any major difference that you notice between what you went through and
what you see now?
A lot more land warfare now.
Yeah.
I think the kids get trained better.
There's so much more to learn under old.
Half our class,
Pauline would have flunked just academic way with what the guys got to know now.
I swear to God we were a frog band.
There was,
you know,
one of them that hard.
But now with all the calm and everything those guys go through,
they teach that stuff and buds,
they teach common buds.
They teach some of it.
Yeah.
Not all of it,
but some of it.
And they,
a lot of ideas when I go out to a San Committee and stuff,
I guess they do,
maybe they don't.
Maybe that's more than SQT,
but yeah,
they gotta use radios and shit there in buds.
But it's just a,
it's a mixture between what we did next QT and what was the frog man.
But I think the frog man part of it,
the EDD part of it is kinda really slacked off.
I think they do a few cursory parallel,
perpendicular recons and stuff like that.
But,
uh,
when I went through,
we were in that fucking how much it was so cold and everybody always says this,
you earned your wetsuit.
Uh,
and it wasn't a full wetsuit.
It was just the,
uh,
well that's for sure.
Yeah,
it was the same with me.
We had,
we had the old wetsuits with beaver tails and we,
even when I went through this is 1991.
Right?
Yeah.
And so it's not like you couldn't get a Doosan good surfing wetsuit because I
surfed and I knew what a good wetsuit was.
So they gave me that Shitty,
a wet suit with the beaver tail with a big Zipper,
big,
loose open.
It looked like a 1970s disco.
There's so much water going through that thing.
It was almost not worth wearing.
Well we,
we,
our first one was in Udt and no fans are nothing.
You are and your friends go,
yeah.
Once you get appreciation,
they had a,
they called a wet suit appreciation and then they fade appreciation.
So to get your friends to,
you know,
and then we got our fans that we still did a couple of swims without the wetsuit
that we got our wetsuit.
And I mean,
it was like Jesus Christ,
you know,
everybody always says,
yeah,
you,
you don't mind cold water d.
And I says,
I've hated cold water all my life.
It's just part of her job and it's what you do.
You know what I'm saying?
You only get wet once.
You know what you just,
Oh,
you're going to get wet.
You can just get it wet one time and that doesn't matter anymore.
But the uh,
I mean,
and there's certain things that I don't think if change,
like there's always been a 5.5 nautical mile swim.
Yeah,
right.
That I don't think that's gotten any shorter.
I don't think that that just is what it is.
A lot of the standards have stayed the same physically and it
fluctuates a little bit.
I think about who's the director over bud and how many times they roll people
and everything back in the day.
I mean,
if our guy was,
it got dropped or something,
he was gone.
Never saw him again.
He was just,
he was just out of there,
you know,
it wasn't come back later.
Maybe they did after a couple of years or something.
Like we had a guy in our class name,
uh,
getting hit.
It had been in class 37,
I think,
and he had broke his hip and then he was in my class and he made it,
you know what I mean?
Really got hypothermia bad.
There was a guy and there was a guy in my class that had rolled back is Jeff
eggs as a matter of fact,
who's a Jujitsu guy.
But he had hypothermia.
They dropped him for hypothermia and he would and he wouldn't.
So they told him,
he's out there like,
you're done.
Hey Man,
listen,
you're a great guy but you can't,
you can't be in the program anymore because you just get hypothermia too easy.
And he's like,
no,
I'm not leaving.
And they gave him his dungarees back,
which is like the regular navy thing that you wear.
And he showed up with the class on Monday with his dungarees zone,
just PT and with the class in the compound.
And they looked at him and they're like,
all right,
we'll give this bastard or another shot.
Yeah,
he was,
he's a hard dude.
And he made it through hypothermia.
He did.
He,
um,
exhaustion.
When you get it to the heat thing,
that'll come back and bite.
You know,
it really does.
I mean,
I swear to
got it.
Hypothermia is like that too.
Yeah.
If you get it real bad case because I knew it was like that with heat
exhaustion,
but I didn't know it was like that with hypothermia.
I think it is.
I mean maybe I'm wrong,
I'm just know that's what I heard.
So I don't know.
Well I'm lucky because I've always been pretty well marbled in terms of
installation is those really skinny lean dudes.
We found out
if you swim as hard as you can,
you usually stay warm anyway.
That's a good boy.
I don't like treading water and cold water.
You know like that swimmer line I was telling you about that was,
that was painful.
God Almighty,
that was cold.
And I told you when we first got the budge,
they had us go down to four oh one and gave us the talk,
you know,
and the guy left he and right here it won't be there seizure to pass a
marshmallow through the keyhole of a needle than make it through and we're all
going,
yeah,
whatever.
And so they marched just all back in front of the bay.
You know,
I told you you were on the bay side.
And then the guy was telling you about come walking out and he kind of look at
us and we're kind of like,
yeah,
how Tufts can this be and everything.
And he said,
uh,
about face forward,
March in March,
this all of their dress blues right in the water.
So you got your flap sticking out like this.
All the white hats floating in.
The officer's hadn't kind of looked at each other.
Damn.
This may not be that easy.
And it went downhill from there,
you know,
get
dressed blues.
Dude,
that's difficult.
Uh,
so you got done,
you got done with being a buds and structure.
You went back and you did a bunch of,
how many platoons did you do back?
I did overall nine.
That's not that many.
But I mean it was good actually.
That is a lot for anyone that's listening and doing nine per period is a lot.
Cause that's nine platoons with workups.
Yeah.
That's like 20 years worth of work right there.
Uh,
um,
and then,
you know,
had her story about you and you got into a fight with some guy at an island.
Oh yeah.
It was like,
ah,
you got into a fight with some guy at nylon was that was this guy that was just
out of prison?
That's the one,
yeah.
Darion yeah.
Somehow.
You know,
I heard the story from my platoon chief and he and he said,
Oh yeah,
you said Roger Aids a toughest bastard alive.
And I had to go eagles.
Yeah.
One time we're out at Niland and there's some guy in a bar and he's,
whenever something happens and you guys throw down and apparently you guys had
like a legit like five maybe 10 minute fight.
Oh it was terrible.
I walked in the bar and I'm just sitting there and he is strong,
kept playing his watch and he rides a saddle and finally I asked the bark Tinder
gotten damn,
can you play a different song guide?
Turns it off in this great big guy stands up.
Like he said he had blonde hair about six,
four.
I think.
Look,
just look those steel blue eyes and stuff and how come you turn that off?
And a bartender pointed right to me.
Well,
he said to turn it off and then the guy looks at me and I went,
hmm,
I don't want to fight.
You know,
just,
you just don't get in fights.
It was so I started walking out the door going across the other bar,
which is right across the street,
like you wouldn't have followed me.
So he follows me out the door and I turned and looked at him and I said,
no,
he's going to follow me over there.
We'll probably warranted fighting.
So I jumped on one foot twice and hit him as hard as I could write in the,
John knocked him down,
his head went like this and,
and hit the wall and some which did right back up.
And I went,
Holy Shit.
You know.
So we did about a 10 minute fight and he actually never hit me one time because
I was just,
I was in really good shape,
you know,
Ireland running and you know what I mean?
And so finally we squares off again.
You know,
and I look at him and he looks at me and I'm covered in blood,
but it's his blood dripping on me cause I just kept,
you know,
have to guide ever hit me.
He had killed me.
He was fighting for fun,
I was fighting for my life.
You know that,
that's the deal.
So we scores off again and finally I went a week,
I'm not tired yet and we can keep on fighting or we can go across the street and
have a beer.
And he thought about it.
He says,
well,
let's go have a beer.
Puts his arm around me.
You know,
you're pretty tough for a little guy and I'm almost crying.
God,
thank God that was probably the toughest fight I've ever been in.
And that guy was a Jesus.
And then I found out he'd been in prison and that's what he did.
His weight lifter and box when he was in prison.
Yeah,
that was how I got out of that.
I'll never know,
man.
That was the punchline was the dude just got out of prison.
It was a weightlifter in a box,
got box or wasn't worn out gas.
A few moments of excitement in that one.
And then you,
uh,
you became a warrant officer.
Yeah,
I was a master chief.
I was master chief of group one and at that was all I was going to do after that
wasn't going to go war calm or anything.
And that's when they came out with a warrant program.
So I put him for warrant and went warrants and then deployed to Desert Storm,
came back.
And then,
uh,
we started the,
that special program I was in.
And he did that for about a year,
year and a half.
And the benevolence of a war come decided we didn't need that anymore.
So they took us all in,
put us into run the first,
uh,
as QT for group one instead of having an,
at the teams.
And then we did that.
And then I went from that to,
uh,
start doing all auris.
That's awesome.
I'll send each step doing or
when I was in my second platoon,
all the guys that all of our new guys went through your,
uh,
your ESCO QT.
Yeah.
We've,
we've been going for like two hours right now.
Just,
um,
I want to get one more question.
Some,
some people listen to the podcast that want to go in the seal teams and you
know,
any sort of thought on what they should be thinking about when they're trying to
get in or trying to go through.
They ask me all the time,
you know,
I always say real simple stuff,
like,
Hey,
do a bunch of pull ups,
pushups,
dips,
swim,
run and don't quit.
And,
and that's how you make it into the seal teams.
And when you get in the seal teams,
you know,
work your ass off.
Well,
you know,
you give it all those kids up at the pretreating,
upper great lakes,
you know,
physically fit perfect.
And,
uh,
if the mental thing,
it's a,
you got to take each day at a time when you get there.
And if you finish that day,
be real happy then get the next day and keep going on.
Don't look ahead of what you gotta do.
But,
uh,
it's like when I was a second time,
I was at bud structure as a master at arms,
you know,
and I'd get all these guys in and I'd tell him,
if you want to do everything we want to do and have the easy life go ELD,
if you think you're going to be a diver and a working diver,
I said,
go be a diver.
And I told him,
if you want to be cold,
wet and miserable,
then go on the seals.
But I will say one thing,
even going through buds and you can probably attest to this,
that just gets you into the teams and then you deploy.
And that's where you pull from what you experienced in bud rather,
where you have to push yourself to the Nth,
you know,
like,
um,
there again,
two and 69,
we were doing this,
uh,
when I was with kilos platoon,
we're going to set up the Sam Bush on this river.
We had to go through about a click and a half of mangroves shit.
And that's where it was all gray and shit from Agent Orange and shit.
I was up to my knees in mud up to my waist in water.
And uh,
when you're holding your up high enough to keep it out of the water and you go
for about a click and a half in that shit using just compass,
because there were,
we didn't have gps and all that shit and you kept going to your rent to the
stream or whatever you're going to set it up on.
He had a strain headache so bad,
you're fucking ice or cross and you're breathing in mosquitoes in your mouth and
spitting them out and shit like that.
That's a,
you do that and you come back and three beers and pat poopers,
you know,
you're good to go.
Or you're in Korea and in Pohang and you got to hit this target,
but you got to go over about three mountain ridges because you can't run the
ridges and Korea.
You got to go up and down them and come out of a submarine and land on the beach
and it's cold and you're,
you're kind of covering why one guys trying to take off his wet suit and he's
fallen down until he gets it off that then you do it and you get about halfway
up the first a mountain ridge before you start getting warm.
That's when you find out a few,
uh,
if you got or not,
the bottom line is,
uh,
we complete the mission,
you know?
Yup.
That's what we do no matter what.
But like I say,
buds,
hell week,
all that shit.
Just get you your mind in the right place to know that,
well,
God damn,
I went through hell week.
I can do this.
You know what I mean?
And other things like the five mile swim and all that stuff.
And that's all.
It's just a,
it's,
it's more I've seen when I was an instructor,
great big guys that were football players fall out and quit.
And I've seen little skinny guys that you'd laugh at and thinking of this guy's
going to be a seal and he makes it through.
It's all because of appearance.
Mine,
you know.
Do you agree?
I mean,
yeah.
And I've always,
you know,
bugs and screening process and you don't actually learn much in buds.
It just gets rid of the people that don't want to be there.
And the real test comes when you,
you know,
when you get into combat,
because going into,
you know,
being cold,
wet and miserable for two or three or four or five days and training and doing a
bunch of push ups doesn't compare it to what you were just talking about or
yeah.
Think of the sand and all that shit that you went through that,
I mean,
I,
I don't like the desert and I don't like coding the mountains.
You can give me the jungle anytime and I'm a happy camper.
Yeah,
I don't like mosquitoes so I'll take the desert or the mountains.
But those are the things,
you know,
I always say that or I always talk about seeing my guys lined up to go out and
Ramadi and their,
their home.
These are lined up and like if I wasn't going on the op,
there's just like platoon was going out and I'd stand there.
I salute them like as they were leaving.
No,
I'd just stand out there and slew them as they were rolling out and what it
takes to be the lead Turret gunner in the first home.
V is more than what it takes to get through buds.
Like that guy who knows that there's been,
you know,
an id on the road,
he's about to drive by.
There's been seven to 10 ideas a on that road and he's the lead Turret gunner
and he's going to roll out again.
And he did it the night before.
He did it the week before and you did it the night before that.
That's what the test is.
Plus or reminded me when I was on that,
um,
Boston whaler to where is he?
He's up at the top right.
What can people see him?
Yup.
Any a rockets or anything like that,
you know where it's going to go.
Yup.
Yeah.
Cause we're gonna want to stop that from shooting,
you know what I mean?
But,
uh,
just so,
just an example,
I mean like when I was in Subic would be,
uh,
we'd take the two weeks was pretty neat because the topography there was you'd
go from triple canopy jungle down to mangrove to where the lower mal was,
which was their,
their,
uh,
fuel places and stuff.
While I'd take my guys up to the,
about four or five of them up to the hospital,
which was up top,
we'd go down through the triple canopy jungle,
worked her way all the way through,
spend the night and come in and hit the lower mouth.
So they had triple canopy,
regular jungle and mangrove swamps type of stuff.
And they were going to just to kind of let them know,
you know,
this is what it was like boys.
Yeah.
That's all.
That's that.
And that's what it's like.
It's like that's why we train hard and to be prepared for that stuff.
So,
yeah.
Awesome.
Awesome advice.
Echo.
Speaking of advice,
do you have any advice on how anyone,
if they want to maybe support the podcast or support themselves,
how they could do that?
Quick,
quick question,
quick question.
You mentioned the booby traps a lot.
Like what kind of booby trap?
What is it like trip wires?
God,
we were ever before when we deployed in,
I don't know if it was,
I think it was 70 71.
We stopped in Hawaii and went to the EOD booby trap course that they had,
that they'd picked up over the years in Vietnam and set it all up.
And after we went through that thing you did,
he want to go over just about,
because it was unbelievable that they would,
uh,
do stuff like,
um,
they'd like to use you guys or call my ids,
but there'd be like mortars up in trees.
And stuff.
And they'd use different methods like a guy named [inaudible].
Yeah,
they got,
he got here with a command detonated a might've been a mortar and you hit him
pretty bad.
But uh,
but sometimes they would take filament down and put a uh,
official,
it's on it so that you'd grab it.
You wouldn't feel it on the bottom,
you know,
and uh,
Paul said off whatever they had set up,
if you usually saw a filament line that was just kind of sagging and everything,
you'd go ahead and cut that.
If it was tight,
she didn't fuck with it.
Like you say,
the smart thing to do is the back way and coming in another direction and the
way the are point scouts did it,
they were really good.
They would take a thin uh,
uh,
branch or stick,
you know,
real thin.
Like just like when you're right,
you can feel all of bite on the line.
They would take that and they would hold a kind of in the center.
And as we're moving slow,
they move.
At any time that thing dipped,
they had reached out and feel it.
Like a lot of other times if you going down a trail,
which isn't a really good idea anyway,
but you step over a log,
sometimes they'd put a pressure detonate and stuff over that log if you stepped
on it.
So you'd always want to go to the side.
Just a myriad of things.
There was a,
Ooh,
a lot of the stuff was command detonated.
Like when we were on those river boats,
there was this place called Snoopy's knows,
you know,
and we'd have the boats going like this,
and when they would turn one group of boats,
another group of volts would be here,
and then they would open up on this group of boats.
So they would shoot across,
but it wasn't that far to the war.
The other boats were,
and they'd started getting hit and thinking,
God damn were being shot at.
Then you go back and forth,
or they would,
uh,
put a beef 40 rocket.
Then they'd be down here in a spider hole,
but they'd have a,
uh,
like singing old pulse,
little and sticking up.
And as soon as the boat got right there,
they would hit the command thing.
Rocco would go off and hit the boat.
Everybody had opened up here and these guys would be giggling,
taken off,
you know what I mean?
Just uh,
just,
yeah.
You know,
the,
uh,
the EOD guys that we had nowadays in the seal teams,
the guys that come and they go through workup with,
they're awesome.
You can't,
you couldn't,
if someone normal person was watching,
they wouldn't be able to tell who's EOD and who's not in at least when we were
in Ramadi,
and that's where most of the EOD guys are.
Like,
but my IUD guys talking about not wanting to go over there,
my EOD guys,
they would,
they would put together briefs of like the latest,
the latest idea that's been out there.
And this is when we're in Ramadi and you know,
every couple,
every maybe like once or once every two weeks they'd put together more of a
detailed brief of like,
Hey,
this is what it does,
this is this thing.
And what we would do is when someone new,
like let's say someone was in from out of town or we had like a visitor that was
going to go on and off with us,
you know,
they'd give that extended brief to teach the guys.
Well,
what it actually did was he would just horrify.
Yeah.
Showed up there with,
through that a course that they had there that became like the joke.
Like I,
you know,
I'd looked at the EOD,
I like,
I see their slide come up and I,
the initial slide and the brief was,
I could tell it was the big brief and I look over at the person that was going,
like our guests,
you know,
maybe it was like a senior officer or someone is going to come or some intel
person that we're going to go out and run off with us.
And I'd look them at the beginning of the EOD brief and you know,
they just have a normal look on their face.
The by the end of 22 slides later they'd looked like they didn't want to go
anymore.
Vc would take these uh,
uh,
[inaudible]
the stone things you have water in itself,
right.
And therefore you're going to a village.
We didn't do,
we didn't usually sweep to villages,
do shit that fill about half of it up with gasoline.
And if they knew the Americans would come in and take a grenade,
wrap up,
save rigors tape or something that would disintegrate,
asked one,
drop it in there.
Then as the guys are going through,
checking out the hooches and everything,
that would go off.
I mean like where if we were going to go into a hooch or something,
we would tie a string to the door and then pull the door open.
Everybody would be down or if we saw something and then where the steps we're
going into it.
Sometimes if we weren't hitting it quick,
you know,
you checked and see what was under the uh,
you know what I mean?
See if there's anything,
but it's just a,
they were ingenious man.
They were really beautiful.
They beat the French and shit.
These guys have been fighting for a couple of years,
you know?
Yeah.
Anyway,
go ahead.
Sorry.
Yeah,
that was it.
That it's crazy how they get smarter and then you guys get smarter with trying
to figure it out.
Then they're like,
okay,
they're trying to figure out this.
So they get sworn in and it becomes,
that's the game and the game does of the game.
Speaking of,
speaking of being in the game like that,
some Alpha brain today,
apparently I did Alpha Brain Alpha brain from audit.
I don't think there is any other kind of Alpha brain,
but nonetheless,
I did take some and we're going to talk about it not for too long.
So anyway,
supplements,
supplementation.
So thinking about this I,
it's taking Krill oil actually is when I was thinking about this,
where would you be if you didn't take any krill oil or any strong bond?
Where would you be?
We don't know.
Behind we're not.
I'll tell you,
you'd be be exactly right.
So,
so it kind of makes me think like,
okay,
you know anyone who's thinking about,
okay Jocko,
Acca,
they'd talk about taking Krill oil all the time,
how much it helps and they didn't start taking it.
You're behind.
So my recommendation is take the Krill oil,
not to mention the Alpha brain,
not to mention any other supplements that will help you get to where you want to
be.
You talk about procrastination sometimes every once in a while.
And that's the biggest thing,
by definition,
that's going to keep you from doing it.
You know,
I get on the supplements,
that's the point there.
And if you want 10% off the supplements that we all know are the best
supplements,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko boom.
There it is.
Support Yourself.
Then you can support others and it's worth the vodcasts.
Boom.
There it is.
Also,
another way to support pod podcast is Amazon click through,
which means before you do your Amazon shopping,
click through the website Jocko,
podcast.com a little banner.
They're
a good and natural way to do it is you know when you shop for the books,
like the books that you cover,
we have a whole page of all the books,
all of them click through there.
Boom.
It will take you right to the books you purchased.
That's a good way to support there is support your brain as well with books and
educating yourself.
Also,
subscribe to the podcast on Itunes,
stitcher,
Google,
play,
all these other podcasting providing platforms.
If you haven't already,
it's a good way to do it.
Leave a review if you didn't in the mood.
If you're not in the mood,
then don't do it or you can still do it if you're not in the little whatever you
want.
Also,
youtube,
subscribe to that Allen.
People who have been subscribing,
that's good.
It's good because it helps spread.
The word seems obvious,
but when you really think about it is not as obvious as you might think because
when you get that alert,
it's not just the whole podcast.
As we always kind of note,
it's like little excerpts,
you know,
a lot of times or a little bit more artistic excerpts,
you'll be more compelled to share those.
And we talk about shareability,
right?
When you get,
when someone shares it with you,
that's one thing and you're like,
okay,
I'll listen to this.
It's only two,
three minutes long.
But on the reverse side,
when you,
uh,
when you're about to share it,
you'll be thinking kind of in the other person's mind.
They're more into listening to it because it's shorter.
It's subtle,
but there's a difference.
So anyway,
if you subscribe,
boom,
that you'll have,
it'll have that effect on you as well.
I know.
Seems magic,
but it's,
it's very explainable.
Anyway,
point there is subscribe to Youtube.
That's a good one.
We'll put more videos on there as well.
Also,
Jocko has a store.
It was called Jocko store,
Jocko store.com.
New Rash Guard is out.
Straight up.
We did it on the Facebook live it,
put it live on that.
You were there.
I was there.
I think it was your Facebook live.
I don't think I've ever done a Facebook live,
by the way.
Anyway,
back to the store.
There's women's stuff on there.
This tee shirts on there.
You have a tee shirt that we gave you a tee shirt,
right?
Last time.
We'll give you another one.
This step two.
They're pretty dope.
There's layers.
It's more to the church.
Then then meets the eye or your kid's shirt is out.
Warrior kid shirts.
Sure.
Adults and children.
Yeah.
Also Jocko uniform.
That's what I'm calling it.
The Jocko uniform.
Oh,
this shirt.
Victory.
Emma man fitness shirt.
You know the actual original.
Sure.
A hundred percent cotton.
Very soft.
Like a jockey.
The lakes in.
Anyway,
from I here I,
this is what I heard.
Anyway.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
If you want to support,
get something,
there's some patches on there to velcro patches,
regulations,
size for the hats.
Actually we got hats coming out too,
by the way.
Oh,
a lot of people been asking.
They're not out.
I'm saying,
I'm saying because when people make these suggestions and a lot of people start
making it okay,
you know,
the more people that make them,
the more um,
we,
we are likely to begin to think about executing.
How you make it sound like such a process,
a long process.
It's a process because you can't just have like two guys saying,
Hey,
we should get,
um,
you know,
I dunno.
Something,
earrings or something in another guy's.
Yeah,
that's cool.
And there's only through exactly right story.
Don't ask.
Boom.
So you mean my point for me,
so Pat's,
we're one of those ones where there was a lot of people saying we need or we
should,
we should have hats.
That would be cool.
And people were like,
yeah,
I think that too.
So anyway,
that's what on the way
somebody is out there.
I already mentioned the rash guard,
I think.
I think we have a lot of good stuff on there,
but only wait for you to find out is to go to Jocko store.com and find out for
yourself if you're in the mood,
get something like that or get something that's on there and it will support the
podcast.
Also,
good way to support yourself in your journey journey.
Are we doing journey or journey?
You've been doing it just so you know.
I know,
but I just,
I have mixed emotions about it was still not comfortable.
Yeah.
I like when other people say and not myself anyway.
And you're getting after it journey,
waking up early,
uh,
sticking to the workout,
sticking to the Diet.
I think that's the,
that's the main one.
You know what I'm saying,
baby.
But don't say,
maybe you were at my house the other day and you were,
what?
Were you eating?
Chicken wings?
No,
there was all bad apple pie.
Was it apple pie?
No,
there was something nonetheless.
As far as diets go,
I went nuts on the chicken wings.
Technically,
the way those were made,
that wasn't much of a deviation from the Diet.
Okay.
Anyway,
the point there being diet is a hard thing.
Yeah,
exactly right,
and that's the point really.
Even Jocko gets nuts sometimes it was a Saturday so that could have been as
cheat day.
Who knows?
But I'm just saying you can be on the program and the Diet thing that'll sneak
up on you,
that'll sneak up on you and you're not ready.
Like if you,
if you have,
okay,
I got to wake up at four 30 you know when the insurgent is going to come is
going to come at four 30 you got to work out at eight 30 or five or whatever
time.
You know when the weakness might come so you can be ready for it.
The Diet thing,
you just don't know.
This is what I'm saying.
So nonetheless he knee moment of weakness.
This is what you do.
You go to iTunes or Amazon music and get an album with tracks called
psychological warfare.
All it is is a bunch of tracks Jocko telling you why you should not skip
workout.
You should not hit the snooze.
You should not eat the donuts.
No donut.
Practical logical
advice from Jocko.
You know why?
Because a lot of people,
they look for inspirational and ice.
This is practical.
Flimsy,
right?
Inspirational.
It's very flimsy because it relies on you feeling like it.
This has nothing to do with feeling.
This has to do by definition with you not feeling like it.
So let Jocko talk you into making the right decision.
That's all it is.
A hundred percent effective.
I dare you to skip the workout after workout and get off whatever the track is
called cause the ones who have them on there because anyway,
against psychological warfare,
iTunes still number one by the way,
that's a check holding,
holding strong,
holding strong for good reason by the way.
Yeah.
Also when you're on Amazon,
you can get Jocko white tea,
which I'm drinking right now and the reason I'm drinking it is because it's
delicious.
By the way.
What does it tastes like?
Your victory,
a way the war,
your kid book came out,
feedback's been unbelievable.
Getting photos of kids doing pull ups,
studying,
doing Jujitsu,
basically getting after it in all realms of getting after it,
which is,
which has been awesome.
And if you want your kid to get after it,
yeah.
Or other kids around your kid to get after it and become stronger,
smarter and better than get them way of the warrior kid.
And I just got an email yesterday from a friend of the family,
69 years old.
Is that considered a kid?
No.
Little bit older than the kids.
Only the kid.
But guess what he said he learned a lot from uncle Jake.
I did.
I just finished it.
Oh you finished this in a few days ago.
I read one or two chapters is every night routine,
boom,
boom with my four year old.
Just feel,
does she understand that she understands a percentage of it?
She's four.
Does she understand the impact?
So this is the plan.
So she's going to understand these really,
really basic things and maybe you know,
I'm gonna just read it over and over and over it.
So it comes to ethos kind of thing.
And then after she gets older,
she didn't start understanding the details and then the more the older she gets,
the more she understands her book.
Boom.
This guy,
friend of the family,
69 years old,
learned from it and then he went,
went and bought a copy for all of his grandchildren and each of them
individually.
So that's good.
Discipline equals freedom field manual thoughts and actions that's coming out.
It's available.
You can get it for preorder right now.
Extreme ownership.
Of course you can get combat leadership applied to business and to life.
So you can get that book.
Also if you want to get in the game,
you can contact echelon,
front leadership and management consulting company that we have.
That contact has infoed echelon front.com also the muster is around the corner,
the Austin,
Texas mustard 13 and 14 of July at the Omni Barton creek resort.
Prag Madec leadership strategies and tactics that you can utilize.
Day One.
No,
no reason to wait around.
You'll learn them and you'll be sending emails in a break to your team getting
things fix.
There's only 300 seats for this cause we wanted a smaller venue and this was the
better venue.
It's gonna sell out.
So if you want to come get your tickets now until the muster,
if you have any feedback or questions for us,
you can find us on actually on the interwebs,
Twitter,
Instagram and on Facebook.
The echo is that Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
Roger of course,
has no social media.
He doesn't care.
Echo.
You got anything else?
I think Roger Hayden again
for coming by.
Thank you so much.
Oh my son's been going to,
you did.
So what are your studio for about six months now and can tell you he loves it.
Yeah,
he was,
went to about two and a half years of this fighting boxing guy that was really
good.
And uh,
but he says that you just saw was a plus the instructors,
you got our top shelf.
He really likes it.
And he told me to tell you,
man,
he really enjoys it.
And thank you.
Yeah,
of course.
Uh,
it's,
it's great to have our GM victory MMA.
It's great to have it.
And to have it,
it's just accessible to people.
There's no walls around it.
It's an open door.
It costs money of course,
cause you gotta pay rent and all that stuff,
but not that much.
Not,
not crazy.
It's 100 bucks a month.
You can train anytime you want,
anytime you want.
Well not 24 hours a day,
but six in the morning until 10 o'clock at night and in other places.
Oh yeah,
like three times as much training,
just Jujitsu.
You got everything there and he shows that's what he likes about it.
Wide Open and uh,
you know,
he likes it.
Yeah.
It's got Jujitsu,
boxing,
Moy,
Thai wrestling,
MMA,
crossfit.
It's got everything in there and that's why we built it.
Uh,
Roger,
you got anything else?
No,
I'm good.
I'm about burnout now.
Well,
Amen.
Once again.
Thanks for coming on.
My pleasure.
Just awesome to have you on here.
And the first time that you were on,
I got a million.
I know you don't do social media,
but I got a million people saying,
please bring Roger back on.
Please bring Roger back on.
And now that you were on today and you once again,
you have a good way of telling little bits of stories that are awesome.
And I want to hear like a one hour story about sea wolves coming in and dropping
bombs and spraying stuff down.
And I'm like,
how does that what guy?
I want to learn the tactics of what was going on.
So you're probably gonna have to annuity you're burned out for today,
but you're probably gonna have to get on one one more time at least.
And uh,
but thanks for coming on again,
sharing your story,
your experience,
your wisdom with us,
and more important.
Of course,
thanks for what you did for our country,
for the navy,
and of course for the teams.
You're absolutely one of the guys that made the teams what the teams are.
So thank you for that,
Roger Honor to have you on here and for the rest of the Vietnam veterans.
And I hear a lot from Vietnam veterans.
Thanks to all of you for holding the line and thank you for every deployment,
for every operation,
every mission,
every day spent out on patrol.
Every night spent out in the Bush,
every helicopter assault,
every river operation,
every combat sortie,
every case of jungle rot and malaria,
and every wound received.
And every brother lost
thanks to you all for what you did for us.
We will never forget.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko and Warren,
officer seal,
Roger Hayden
out.